which one
resource
well good morning everyone being a
little close to 9 30.
we have the department of administrative
Services I see
few folks I recognize
now welcome
and this is on page 56 for those of you
following it along in the budget book
oh yes that's that's what we think too
that's a good sign
I I ended up saying to to Sherry um last
night I said our page numbers are they
their page numbers and are we I mean are
we working off the same version of the
document because I I did this once where
we weren't and the page didn't mess
everybody up so we we are I'm Charlie
arlinghaus I'm the commissioner of
administrative services and with me is I
want you uh Catherine Keane Cassie you
may call me I'm the Deputy Commissioner
of Das and I have a lot of people with
me in case you have questions because I
might not be able to answer them in fact
very likely
um so Sherry Rockburn is in the front
row and Sherry also did the slides so
that's very exciting sure is the
assistant commissioner and we try to
avoid calling her the new Joe Bouchard
because that seems unfair
but occasionally that helps people
understand
in the back row is our CFO Maureen Ryan
Hoffman next to hers Kathy Schmidt
um in who we're both part of our Central
Finance office and then the front row
for whom you may have more questions
than for me is Karen rantamaki who is
our director of plant and property she's
right
was there okay
so excuse me between us we should be
able to answer any questions I'm going
to go through the presentation because I
thought rather than going accounting
unit by accounting unit which we we can
do if you if you want
um I'll summarize some things
and it'll help um understand some so
looking at our presentation
I've talked to you about who we are and
why you should care that we're a central
Service Agency I'm not going to go
through that again but just the notion
that um of the the many varied things
that we do as an agency and how they
affect everybody else but that's there
for your reference I'm going to skip to
page four
page four which is titled how do we
spend
um it feels like I should be a song how
do we um anyway the um
I I broke it up in a couple of ways when
I want to use this slide to explain to
you a little bit about who we are one is
that
um there are five groups we refer to as
attached boards these are independent
administratively attached agencies
um they're our friends they're our
family but they're not we're not the
boss of them and so I so I say that we
do some administrative things helping
them out
um with finance and HR and a couple
things like that but they're independent
agencies so
um there's time you have on your
schedule to talk to them about their
budget
um and it's not something that we
control so I just say that um so that
everybody understands because
um administratively attached agencies
are something that there's often a lot
of misunderstanding about in um
in various quarters of state government
and how they really are completely
independent agencies they just happen to
be very small agencies one of them is
actually literally a staff of one but
they're nonetheless an agency just in
the same way HHS is just slightly fewer
people
um
I'm going to talk to you about retiree
Health plant and property and then
everything else we do
um and it's
one way to think of our budget and I
often think of it this way is we're two
agencies we're retiree health
and we're administrative Services
retiree health is a is a separate
program it's not an it's not an
operational thing that we do it's a it's
a it's a benefit that we pay and
um what happens there is slightly
different you know there's not staff
there's not we have staff who administer
it but that part of the budget is a um
is a benefit that's administered and and
so we we think of it very differently
the rest of it is the operations of the
department that we do I say plan
property because they're half of the
rest of the department it's the biggest
thing that we do is take care of
buildings I don't mean it's the most
important thing we do but the day your
heat goes out it is the most important
thing we do the water leaks from the
second floor ladies room into your
office I speak hypothetically as
somebody whose office is under the
second floor ladies room and had a leak
into it it did actually happen I was out
for three weeks
so that's us you got a leak we fix it um
that's Karen actually
um not literally every leak she's not
out there with a with a monkey wrench
but um still she could be
um so those are pieces you're going to
see in our budget something called
Central facilities expense which is an
additional
um
double budgeting mechanism that's
created and it's created and I'll
explain it um at the end of our
divisions uh a way to more accurately
and precisely account for expenses
instead of a sort of ham-handed way
we've done it in the past
I'm gonna go to slide five where do we
spend General funds Finance committees
tend to be particularly concerned about
General funds
and I want to make the point here that
you know the governor's targets were
were relatively tight for most agencies
for every agency
and I just point this out to show you
that we actually hit the governor's
Target we're down three percent off of
adjusted authorized and then up and and
then up in the second year as everybody
is but um we made a very significant
effort in the efficiency budget and in
what the governor ended up proposing uh
uh to propose a very very tight budget
and so if you look at that at the bottom
of page five
um it's really very I think it's very
strong and I now I'm going to go through
the divisions one by one commissioner
you don't mind if you take some
questions I'll take questions at any any
time at any moment representative
McGuire thank you Mr chairman thank you
commissioner so
um on this page I just want to ask
because we're here right sure look at
the commissioner's office line and look
at 22 actuals compared to the rest yes
so what happened uh legal settlements
legal settlements are not budgeted but
are paid out of a out of an accounting
unit that is within the office of the
commissioner activity code so every year
at the end of the year that
that particular activity code ends up
looking large in this particular case
there were something like 6.2 million
dollars of settlements that were paid
that um significantly inflates that
number and so so that is something I
should have pointed that out because we
actually
we actually talked about that and I and
I forgot to mention it so thanks for
noticing so all the other things are
going up to some degree I mean it looks
flat right but but there's a mission
piece there that's going to come along
presumably it is is that 6 million
unusual do you know what the history of
that
um the 6 million is not I can get you
the history of that the 6 million Is Not
Unusual we have
um
we have settlements and and I'm going to
guess but I think they vary between
maybe four and 10 million a year and but
why don't I look up the history of that
but um so maybe we should have a budget
number rather than a zero becoming 6
million
um there are it's it's accounted for in
the kafir but um
it's a good question I mean maybe we
should have a budgeted number but um let
me do a let me do a history Jerry do you
have something
full history but I was just going to
reference reference
say 99 Colon D is the RSA that allows
for the legal settlements to be paid as
they're incurred and they're funded from
funds not otherwise appropriated and the
governor can draw a warrant against any
settlement that comes in so that's
because that RSA exists it traditionally
hasn't been budgeted and then if we do
have a settlement our department will
issue a warrant on behalf of the
governor to make those those payments
out the door RSA number again yep
99-d colon 2.
so 99d2
yeah so the concept is if we budgeted
something maybe that would incentivize
people to sue us is that the problem or
I I don't want to say that's true
because I I think the people who
represent the people suing
kind of
um don't think that they're limited by
whether money is appropriated or not so
I don't think I don't think it's
actually an incentive but I don't think
it would be a horrible idea to set money
aside for it if you in a year where you
had money to set aside you'd probably
want to create a separate
non-lapsing accounting unit and uh
why don't we why don't we get you a five
six seven year history of of what we've
paid uh and source of funds and because
typically the settlement comes from
if a tree falls on you in the Parks and
you sue the parks fund would pay for
that if you something happens on the
highway the highway fund would pay for
that and so a lot of it is General funds
but not entirely thank you
attack
oh well I know
there's something to be said for that
too much time on this but the justice
department gives a fiscal committee a
list of the settlement amounts so this
those settlement amounts basically paid
from your account I guess yes it's a lot
of things like that were they somebody
else takes an action and we write a
check all right thanks so
um
but yes these are routine thing that
comes through when we process them very
quickly it's it's one of the things
somebody told me when I started these
can't sit on your desk
like when you're when you're I spend
half my day signing things but this is
something where they said you know it
comes in we're not sticking in a folder
it's presented to you and it's so
um so I want to skip ahead to Page Six
um operational challenges I'm gonna I'm
gonna lead with this rather than ending
with this and this is functionally the
the three things we're going to ask you
for
um that aren't in the budget and so I
thought you know let's just be upfront
about that
um and there are three areas and they're
not in in a priority order because
they're sort of of equal Priority One is
moving costs and fed up for swing space
it's one of the challenges we have
routinely and people have noticed this
with the parking garage moving moving of
Justice debate and all of that and
additional people are going to have to
move there is moving costs are never
budgeted or planned for
um we're going to be doing a significant
renovation on the on the State House
Annex which is which involves all the
mechanical systems Etc and there's a lot
of moving that goes on with that and
moving costs are fairly expensive
it's a bill for granite play Slash
moving Justice slash the parking garage
last year
had a placeholder of 1.2 million dollars
for moving costs and so what I what I am
going to ask you for is is could we
consider doing that
um for uh the rest of the moves in in
state government
um
for moving people around both with the
annex renovation the likelihood of
buying Granite place and moving other
agencies into it
um you know for example what if
agriculture moves from the annex into
Granite place they have no money
budgeted for for moving
um and then Hall Street which apparently
the capital budget contemplates buying
as well the old Granite State College
Bear right building
two new positions
and I know how the committee looks upon
new positions but I'm going to ask
um
the one question is purchasing agents as
as some of you know the governor and
Council undertook a significant change
this year commodity contracts did not
used to go to governor and Council
um you know I think that things that go
to governor and Council involve a great
deal more work than things that don't go
to governor and Council
so um the the division of procurement
has essentially had their workload I
don't want to say doubled because it's
not quite that bad but it's close to
that and
um what I'd like to do is ask for three
new purchasing agents Rank and file
purchasing agents not not managers not
semi-directors or anything like that but
just on people to people to get the job
done because of the significant
additional effort it's a cost associated
with that
the HR coordinator positions would be a
conversion we stood up a recruitment
unit
with arpa funds at uh at the division of
personnel we we think it's going very
successfully it's identifying
significant operational challenges that
exist in the state and that we're
um and that the there is an ability to
um
there's an ability to uh
make a significant operational change
for the state you know in the state with
a 20 vacancy rate this is a big thing so
what we'd like to do is to make those
positions permanent as opposed to
um temporary arpa positions and I I hope
you would consider
um smiling upon that or part of that and
then the third thing is deferred
maintenance
um as representative Weiler's leaky
stairwell story indicates
um we have a lot of leaky bucket Roofing
Etc related issues and
um deferred maintenance is always an
issue and one thing we had looked at
um trying to do frankly in the
governor's phase and and we didn't get
it and I'm so I'm asking you
um is 3.6 million we would we would ask
it be appropriated to the maintenance
fund
by doing that it becomes a one-time
expense
as opposed to uh um an ongoing effort
you know the we'll talk we can talk
about the maintenance fund when we get
there and how it's funded but the idea
of that fund um which is this committee
and the Senate created uh four years ago
I think
was to fix things that need fixing as
opposed to fixing things in an
accounting unit that happens to have
money left over so fix the roof that's
most broken not the roof where we happen
to have money left over so those are the
three things I'm going to essentially
ask you for so if you remember that
during our presentation it's there
so turning to Pardon Me turning to page
seven
I know that Kennedy has an interest in
um
in uh vacancy rates and and how we're
doing
um and so this is just a description of
our of our 311 full-time classified and
unclassified positions where are we and
the vacancy rate is is roughly flat I
like to think we're doing a great job
and keeping up I mean we hire
to give you an idea in our agency we
hire something between 100 and 130
people every 12 months
and a lot of those are part-timers have
maybe half part-time half full-time and
there's a turnover with people going to
other agencies but we're we're happy to
be a sort of a net net improver of our
position not every not every agency is
but we make an effort to only make an
effort to be a nice place to work so
that tries to get you some people
um so
yes question represents McGuire thank
you so
um this says 311 which is the current
number but the budget on page 127 says
you're going up to 328.
so yes
um I guess you'll talk as we go along
yes we'll go if you want we'll go
through division by division and I'll
talk about that yeah a number of those
are
committee should be aware of this
the 311 number that's in the budget
document tends what one does not include
part-time positions does not include
full-time temporary positions does the
so-called class 59 positions and um
part of our increase of the line share
of our increases the conversion of some
of those 59 positions into regular class
10 classified positions and I can talk
about those agency by agency as we go
and then a couple of a couple of things
here and there
um where there were additions to our
list
and Sherry's actually sitting next to me
with a giant breakdown of
because she spent time last night
reconciling our position comes
um so I'm going to start with the
commissioner's office which is in your
budget book is page 56 to 63.
the commissioner's office is not
um just me and
my coffee machine I don't I don't
actually have a coffee machine that's
not permitted under State rules
um
it's it includes the state budget office
the Department Of Central Finance office
or business office including Human
Resources payroll Etc the office of Cost
Containment which is a small program the
Deferred Compensation commission is in
there our rules and procedures office
which are lawyers who work on rules
um so various assorted things in that
group as well
the numbers here
um
the numbers here include a couple things
and I've highlighted for you
um the slight increases we
we wanted to budget an additional fifty
thousand dollars for overtime across the
department department and because of the
New Hampshire first upgrade that is
going to happen
um and and what I did is budgeted in
this
in the commissioner's office for
distribution
as opposed to budgeting in one division
or another and frankly the reason we did
that was to allow us to make operational
decisions about
um you know what's happening in in uh in
the group that manages New Hampshire
first what's happening in the in
accounting services which is going to be
responsible for much of the financial
part of the system and where can that
money be uh best allocated
um and I think that makes a lot more
sense than trying to hire additional
people take the people that we have and
to the extent that they have capacity to
work extra hours work them extra hours
um
some of the uh our class 30 line for
equipment
um has
um some has a significant increase in
fiscal 24. excuse me
um for Furniture's fixtures and
equipment the kind of things that go
along with that with any kind of a
renovation and particularly as you as
you change your format and you use it as
an opportunity to discard old furniture
if you've wandered through the Annex in
particular you'll notice that furniture
Never Dies
but there's some that we think really
really ought to be retired
um
in addition to that the agency has spent
almost no money in recent years on
training it's something that most
employees would like it's something that
we would like to do I remember two years
ago I approved sending someone to um to
training and someone said okay
um where are we going to get the money
and I said well what do we have in the
training line on the budget and they
said a hundred dollars and it's a twenty
six hundred dollar course I'm like okay
so maybe we'll do that next year
and so there's a little bit of that and
so what we want wanted to do and again
that's centralized for the agency as
opposed to for us in addition to that we
uh we we plugged 250 000 to fund
upgrades for the Statewide budget system
the budget system people
um probably know is a very complicated
system is a relatively old system it's
run by a company called AGS
um and it's sometimes called bars you'll
hear referred to it's it produces the
joint document in front of you uh it's
something that we we work on with the
LBA we have within our budget office one
of our business supervisors Steve
McLaughlin who's a who's very computer
talented
um
uh had talked a lot about
um uh improving the system to to change
a lot of things that are manual
um and make them uploadable for example
and and we think we could do something
in that budget range for that system to
make the system better rather than
having to procure a new budget system I
mean at some point we are going to have
to procure a new budget system it's just
something that happens you can't keep
putting Band-Aids on the old system as
the underlying architecture works with
changes but it's something we we wanted
to do
um and then the other theme that I want
to mention to you
is that you will see that our class 27
doit costs are budgeted by division now
instead of in one spot so the doit costs
are allocated to agencies through class
27. we used to budget them about
two and a half million dollars in one
line in one division one accounting unit
in our agency which makes it seem like
um fdm it was at the time is the only
people who use computers in the entire
agency well that's not the that's not
the right way to budget it's just what
we happened to do for for 20 years so
we're trying to budget the right way
there
that's the commissioner's office
if you look at page nine it's accounting
services
which is 63 to 65 in your book
accounting services is the or you might
think of them as the office of the
Comptroller or occasionally referred to
as boa despite the fact that those
aren't their initials in um in state
government often and this is the
accounting oversight the the
Statewide payroll office is here and the
um and they obviously they do the
aquifer every year as well and this is a
this is one of those areas that's a very
simple budget
um and it's something that we hope no
one ever notices
but if we didn't have it we would have
to cease operating as a state
um but one of those things that you the
accounting and they do a particularly
good job
um nothing much is nothing much is
different here uh the one thing we did
ask for but didn't receive in in the
budget
um
you know with our there's a lot of
reporting requirements happening and
there was some discussion with gopher
about whether there would be a reporting
position there that we worked with or it
would be easier for them to just have
the reporting position in admin services
and the thought was that well it should
be in admin Services because after all
that's that's where we do the single
federal audit that's where we do most
reporting
um and so they
graciously told us to ask for it in the
budget and we were graciously told no
so
uh division of personnel is something
people have a lot of interest in these
days particularly when vacancy rates are
high or when you're looking for a job
frankly
um
so not to interrupt you commissioner
please saying that you would like us I
would like to consider that 190 yes I
would thousand dollars added into the
budget I would I think um if we are
going to do significant reporting on
um
if we're going to do significant
reporting on arpa and we are going to
have to for for years to come
um we have a we have a class 59 position
that's currently doing some work on that
but will it like like all the class 59
our positions will expire on June 30th
um which is something we should talk
about at some point about it's been
added to our list thank you
thanks
um division of personnel
um Statewide hiring and procedures and
and this is an area where I know there's
some interest from in various pieces of
the committee about the reform of the
classification system that's ongoing
um the state's Bureau of Education and
Training is run out of this division
um the Statewide training
um in addition to that over the last
couple of years we created a an hrsu we
call it
there's there's been a lot of discussion
for the last
15 maybe years about centralizing or
decentralizing uh some back office
functions but HR being one of them
and what we figured out we think we
figured out is that that's the wrong
question that it should be both
centralized and decentralized and if
you're an agency like um
well let's say HHS right the biggest
agency in the state they've three
thousand in some positions and they
haven't they have an HR staff of 25 20
28 28 thank you
um which is actually bigger than our
division of personnel and um
probably their employees are getting a
commensurate level of service with that
but if you're a relatively small agency
agencies of fewer than 100 100 employees
you either don't have you might have one
HR staff you probably don't you probably
have somebody who's assigned to do
you know this and this and this and one
of the this is is HR you probably do a
great job given your level of training
and experience but your level of
training and experience is probably
slightly less and
um and then there are a bunch of
agencies that just don't have that so
what we did and most of this is done
through accept and expend through fiscal
right now is we created a support unit
to um to create
an order of magnitude that makes that
work and so they're managed centrally
through the division of personnel and I
think right now it's something like
eight agencies small agencies
yeah about that it's it's less it's
fewer than we hoped it's fewer than we
hope but anyway that's something that
exists
um and that's why one other one
um well there there is because of the
the workload in personnel which you know
this committee's heard about for 20
years
um there was a position added in in the
budget
um and the thing I want to remind you
that we talked about was converting the
Statewide recruitment unit
um is is our big ask here
and so in this particular unit
um the most significant change the most
significant increase is related to the
the doit funds being placed in the unit
instead of not so representative McGuire
as we go through we talked about the 17
positions that were added this was the
first of the I'll say new positions as
we go through this just to give you the
um the heads up the preview we'll have
three positions that will come up this
is the first of the three the remaining
positions are the result of conversions
things that were in temporary positions
that are becoming permanent so it's not
that there is a new position added to
the budget it looks new in the terms of
how the reporting works in the budget
document so of the 17 there's three
brand new and this is one of those three
a bit more
correct that is not in anything
okay correct
okay that that's Personnel since there's
a little break does anybody else have
any questions so far
I do have since we're on Personnel we've
heard it from the governor that he was
proposing a 10 across the board pay
increase which I guess is in house bill
too so none of your numbers include any
of the benefit impact of that or the
cost of that and I understand from the
LBA it's what in the neighborhood of
about a hundred million dollars is that
I think that's right yeah it's just shy
it's around maybe 98 million of salary
and benefit
to account for a 10 and 2 percent then
that all of that is in house bill too
and is that classified and
non-classified or is it everyone's
getting that increase when we so
typically when we budget an increase as
a there's a the reason there's
legislation on it is that you you extend
that to legislative judicial branch
employees you extend it to unrepresented
employees you extended to unclassified
employees and and then various assorted
things as a as a whole file we have at
home so to speak on on this and how we
do that but yes it's not some people
don't get a raise and other people don't
everybody everybody would so
um hopefully we'll see complete House
Bill 2 shortly that's what I've heard
so but I think that that my
understanding is that's like literally
what it is it's a 10 the the CBA and the
unions talked about this as well
um the CBA that they reached tentative
agreement on is uh 10 on July 1st and
then two percent on the next July 1st
represent Maguire I guess that's a
question yeah so so what you're saying
is if we see a class 10 or a class 11
line those don't include those that 12
increase is that right so if there is an
increase these are all either new
positions or step changes
yes okay thank you
um representative the other thing I
would point out which is also a theme
throughout um it's it's primarily
highlighted in the bullets but we
haven't talked a lot about it is a lot
of the 22 lower costing is really a
result of vacancies in a lot of areas
and so the 23 to 24
budget doesn't look like it's growing as
much that's normally it's going to be
step increases things of that nature 22
going into 24 22 to 23 is really a
result of vacancies and a lot of our
areas are getting better with our
vacancies but that's the other driver
that you know why does 22 look so low so
I just want to point out that some of
that 10 and 60 line is the result of
that
so are you saying hiring at the end of
22 was pretty good is that I think it's
fair to say hiring is improving and I
think that um
I mean we could talk for a couple hours
on on this whole thing but uh um the the
state the state is getting uh is getting
more applicants is doing a better job
hiring and is bringing more people on
board we have a lot of people leaving
and it's a it's a it's a churn issue
right and I I I'm using my agency as an
example if we hire 120 people and we
have 118 people leave it looks like
all you did over the last year is hire
two people it's a lot of work to hire
120 people it's a lot a lot of time and
I you know and I uh Cassie and I are
sharing I do a final interview with all
of them too so it's you know think of
the number of hours that is which I
think is important but I think the
state's doing a much better job and I
think if we were If This Were a year and
a half ago we would be
forlorn in talking to you we would be a
little bit down in the mouth on it I I
feel I feel very good Cassie's writing
something important
um I just wanted to point out that it
looks like it's good that we're doing
okay we're keeping up but um there are
certain kinds of positions that are
nearly impossible to hire and in our
department that's Engineers right and
that's in our division of Public Works
and um and we also administer the
Statewide Enterprise computer system and
it's really really hard to hire I.T
people and recently we hired two people
and they left within a month or six
weeks because they had better
opportunities for the record they liked
it
and I didn't leave because of us
and they and they and it's just
important they made that clear but in in
fact in both cases they left for jobs
that were
100 remote which we're not and
um and in both cases the one guy said he
doubled his money and the other guy said
he got a 50 pay raise and I I asked the
head of that Division and he said
he said I don't know the exact numbers
but I think they're right so that's an
issue the other at the at the at the
other
um end of the wage scale we have an
enormous vacancy rate among building
service workers cleaners Etc
um and it's it's it's hard to
you know when when Dunkin Donuts pays
really well and and you don't have to
clean toilets although you probably do a
little but anyway
well so far we've heard nobody that
doesn't like you so that guess that
could be concerning but thank you we do
have representative Wilder with a
question
thank you Mr chairman uh commissioner I
thought I saw a while ago like a 10-year
listing of total employees in the state
and it didn't seem to show much
variation
over the 10 years now I don't know how
it was put together but it didn't seem
to reflect this 20 vacancy we're hearing
and we also go to the treasurer and say
how many paychecks are you issuing and
those those numbers come close too so it
it doesn't make sense either either
we're not either they're listing just
the positions
or they're listing the people that are
getting paid I don't know which well
there are there are I've actually done
some looking into this myself because I
had a very similar question and um
the um
so you know the good news and the bad
news so the good news is that that I
think you're right that the total number
of employed classified employees I'm
going to use that as a sort of a
baseline number because it doesn't
there's not a big question about what's
included in that or not has not
dramatically changed that is number of
people employed versus vacancy right
that's why vacancy rate can be
misleading
hasn't changed dramatically Howard has
changed and you know we were at some
point a little over
um I'm making numbers up I don't have
them with me but a little over nine
thousand and maybe we dip down to more
like more like um 8 500 8400 8300
but it's not a question of we used to be
at ten thousand and now we're at seven
or something like that it's more about
moving up and down within a
maybe thousand employee range out of ten
thousand positions and that's not
dramatic
depending on where they are right if if
I if you told me
we have to run our department forever
and ever with
uh
ten percent of our positions permanently
vacant but the other ninety percent
would always be full
and I would never lose anybody
um I could make that work if I could if
I could pick the positions and we could
we spent a lot of time on it but what
what happens is there's this there's
again this churn that goes on and so the
state historically has has had a had a
10 to 12 vacancy rate maybe if you look
at Personnel reports I only went back
about 20 years but if you but if you
look at them they there's not a huge
variation
um and it was in that range and it's
lately it's gone up but it's also true
that the number of authorized positions
in the last let's just say five or six
years has gone up not dramatically but
um of a substantial number and so I
would say that yes
it's not huge but there's no question
that we're
we're in a valley and it's a discernible
Valley
representative McGuire thank you so is
churn save money not just in the sense
that somebody leaves and it takes two
months to hire somebody to replace them
but also in the sense that it's the
person retiring or leaving is at a
higher step and when the new one comes
in to fill this position it starts at
the ground floor
yes sort of I'm gonna
um
yes I mean there's no question that that
it's true that
the gap between employees saves the
state money there's there's I got two
months where you're not paying anybody
or three months or six months or pick a
number that number of months that you're
not paying anybody and typically the
people who leave and the people who come
in it's higher versus lower although in
a tight labor market we're not really
hiring at that different a salary when
the new person comes in the only thing
uh the counterbalance to that though is
is operational that
the the state's hiring managers do a
decent job they they generally do a good
job but we don't we don't hire
supervisors on the basis of their
expertise in hiring people and I'm going
to use Karen's behind me for a minute
and you know Karen Karen's hired because
she's she's an engineer she's a very
good engineer from Caltech and Etc and I
don't think she um
I don't think she took a lot of job a
lot of courses in hiring when she was
there and when we evaluated that
position and uh this is when we're
Cassie and I did do a final interview
um and um we didn't ask her
um how much training do you have in
hiring and how much time of your
schedule can you devote to hiring and
when you when you have too many
vacancies you end up spending an
inordinate amount of your time
um hiring people and dealing with that
it's a long process there's a lot of
applications that come through if you
want to do a good job you have to turn
them around really quickly and you have
to interview a lot of people you should
not just interview one people because
one person because I think we've all had
an experience where jeez he looked great
in the interview
I thought he was I didn't realize he had
that that issue with PTSD and or
whatever and the
um and so that's that's the cost and if
you have you have your your senior
people spending too much of their time
um just trying to fill positions day in
and day out and not doing the
it's a value add that theoretically
you've hired them for
um there's a cost associated with that
but there's no question that on the
balancing side just in terms of spend it
does reduce the spend I mean the lapse
we've had relatively High lapses in
recent years
um silly high and it's because of
employee positions being vacant okay now
um
let me ask you about this other thing
where you said you can't hire for
certain positions doit Etc
um is that because the the
classification system is really got some
problems in those areas right certain
jobs are misclassified or the the
baseline or whatever of those things are
wrong
I mean we've heard the exact same thing
out of Corrections well
it's I I think there's a lot to it I
don't want to say they're classed wrong
and we'll let Cassie talk about this too
but um
one of the things about a large
complicated system like the state is
you're doing a you're doing an
evaluation where you're
cross-referencing everybody against
everybody else and it's not possible to
do that in a way where there are some
positions that aren't
where you don't capture market trends
all the time and that there aren't some
positions that are not captured and and
the truth is that even where we're
having trouble hiring people we hire
some people
but you you have to try to hire somebody
who's thinking and put it this way the
attraction one of the attractions to the
state is work-life balance it is it is a
job where you are literally not allowed
to work more than 37 and a half hours
um it is a it is a job where you get
um and for some people they're like I
need I'm at a point in my life I want to
just like like calm down a little bit
work hard but not for 60 hours and then
and then if I'm honest um our health
benefits are really quite an attraction
but not to 25 year olds
I don't know that I have too much to add
to what Charlie said but the current
process allows for something called a
reallocation of a position so if if a
department thinks that they have a class
of employees that are not properly
classified they can say this is what
they do we can compare it against what
the old job description used to be and
we review that and we then adjust the
position if appropriate and I'm thinking
back a couple years ago we did that with
state troopers they were moved up a
labor grade because they had new new
computer-related duties in their job
that they didn't previously had when the
job was classified so that kind of tool
reallocation is available to something
like the Department of Corrections for
their Corrections Officers in the in the
new system that we're working on we're
working on a component that will allow
us to go out to Market on positions and
compare and it doesn't mean there's
going to be an automatic adjustment I
mean even private employers go out to
Market and say what are we paying nurses
doctors whatever and and they make
decisions about well what do we do about
this right do we want to adjust do we
not want to adjust in our circumstances
we'd probably have to take that that
information into account when we go back
to the table for collective bargaining
and I I would just add to that um
related to things we talked about before
I think everybody who sits in this chair
these chairs is going to some point say
to you that the the obstacle to my
hiring people is money
that we we don't compete financially on
salary we compete very well in benefits
um and I'm I'm not not going to say that
I it's true that that
um you know lately we can't hire anybody
except one or step two it's just not
possible and it we're out of Market
um
I don't want to over emphasize that
though the the state the state's ability
to compete is always been multifaceted
the attraction of a state job there
there are a bunch of components one is
public service and don't minimize that
that's very real one is uh benefits
right it just benefits the other is that
the state as an Enterprise is very
unlikely to close
it's not true of Fred's construction the
state is very unlikely to close that's a
benefit
um it is true that on salaries we have
lost significant ground to inflation and
historically we've kept up and we lost
something like 15 16 to inflation over
the last let's just say five years pick
a number
um and and I so I I say that I think you
know a 10 raise for example
it's really quite large right it's huge
by historical standards on the other
hand we still won't have kept up with
inflation and so
you know if I'm doing a spreadsheet at
home
and and I do because I'm a little geeky
but
um I know what CPI is and I know what my
salary is and I know whether it's kept
up or not and uh it I think that will
make a difference in in two ways
one is that it is a wage adjustment it
does make make us a little more
competitive the other is that is that
there's a psychological effect of it
being you know maybe this isn't an exact
cost of living adjustment but 10 sounds
very real and I think there are there
are a number of people who are sitting
who are sitting
um particularly good people who are
competitive people who I really don't
want to lose thinking you know what
point do I decide I really need to like
um take the money and I think this
reduces the incentive to take the money
okay
procurement and support services
uh page 11 107 to 119 in your in your
book at home this is a very uh
complicated I've I've uh I don't want to
let this meeting go without explaining
to you that our department
it has lots of little nooks and crannies
and I say we're like a big English
muffin of state government
um and I'm sure somebody was afraid I
wouldn't say that but I I did
um nowhere is that more true than in
this division this is purchasing
this is where we buy stuff this is
Statewide purchasing but it also
includes a whole bunch of other little
things surplus food distribution which
is run out of a warehouse on store
Street it includes Surplus property the
state unlike the federal government
sells its property when it's done with
it we also we also grabbed the federal
Surplus too because why not
um and we sell it at White Farm some of
you have been to the surplus auction
there some of you have been there lots
of knives there lately if you want to go
because they get stopped at the airport
um we do this is where the merchant card
program the state's credit card programs
are done out of it's where the P card
the state where we use a credit card is
done out of it's where Fleet Management
is done out of it's where Real Property
Management the state has one real estate
lawyer
um he's a nice guy he may be a little
overworked but he's a good guy and he's
out of this division too
um
anyway that's what this division is it
includes in the budget it's also where
graphic Services is I'm sorry people are
aware of that Statewide graphic Services
is managed also out of a building on
store Street
um out of this division
um
and that's that's where a lot of the
other income from comes from the agency
income basically we we print stuff for
safety safety pays for it and it's it's
a centralized function there's one new
full-time administrator position here
and it's
um we have a lot of purchasing agents
and it's and it's one basically Gary
London said I want I want one more
senior manager I need that they do
contracts too but they also help the
junior managers and and bring them along
we have a very good purchasing staff
um and they do a good job
um
uh some of the increases their dit costs
are here and the mail the centralized
mail unit which used to be in plant and
property is going to be in the next
budget in procurement and support
services uh frankly just because it's a
support service and the sway the
property people aren't
we maintain buildings and deliver the
mail now they maintain buildings
delivering the mail to somebody else so
um this is where I want to ask for three
new purchasing agents because of the
increased volume required for governor
and Council
so
I will note that purchasing is the
oldest part of our agency having been
established with a purchasing agent in
1915.
president of hedge followed by
representative McGuire
we um the
um this year the governor and Council
decided that they now want to see
commodity contracts instead of just
service contracts so there's an enormous
amount of volume increase that didn't
used to exist
um and there I'll just say they're a
little I mean they're great people but
they're a little overwhelmed right now
sir
ens
thank you
no that so so in the past uh commodity
contracts because they're typically done
by bid right there's so you know how
much you're going to charge us for road
salt didn't go to council because they
they didn't necessarily look at them
there's a subset of counselors in
particular who thought you know I want
to see contracts and some who have been
there a while who have always wanted to
see commodity contracts and would like
to see any contract I could you know the
more the merrier and
um historically it hadn't been done
because it seemed like
um there would be less debate discussion
or need for oversight of that and
um
it is what it is and I said to the
council
will administer whatever you pass
because that's what we do but um I do
know that there are a bunch of agencies
who are saying to themselves I don't
understand why what are they looking at
in the in the fuel contract what are
they looking at in this but I think the
I think the council probably feels the
councils who are adamant about this that
there's a sense of the governor and
Council process the more things they see
the more
uh corruption can be avoided good
practices implemented Etc and it I I do
believe that the governor and Council
process in the state creates a a
transparency that doesn't exist in a lot
of States on procurement and you know if
I were on the council would I want to
see commodity contracts I I think maybe
I wouldn't but I'm not on the council I
didn't run for office and they get to
decide but it just it just that there's
a lot of work that's associated with it
I'm just a lot of work with I'm I'm not
kidding so when uh no that's okay uh oh
the benefit
um
that's the question I would ask the
counselors okay
sorry I don't mean I don't mean it that
way but you know what I mean yeah
it's okay well on the related issue I
mean it's up it's not up to them right
it's up to law what they see we could
change law so they wouldn't see this
right there there's a that's probably a
discussion for the Attorney General
there's a there's an argument about
um
because the council has required
constitutionally to approve all funding
I think that it is their General
position that they may request to see
anything they please okay
I'm just where are my head's going cost
benefit and and I think I heard you say
that there is a
considerable additional cost to
accommodate this and I'm still not
connecting any benefit I I think what
the council hopes is that they will see
things in contracts that they can
um squash or turn or avoid or suspend
and uh save us money that way or improve
bidding practices
they're hoping for efficiency and
transparency
is I think their points
okay thank you whether that comes to
pass or not is a separate question can I
get to know how much this is costing us
someday
so uh talk about the the sort of two
million dollar difference between actual
and and future and this page
um there are a couple of there are a
couple of components of that
um uh the one is significant vacancy
rates the other is that is that we uh is
that we carry costs in in graphic
services for example which is a
self-funded largely self-funded entity
there's a there's a general fund
component to it
um where if we have the business there
are positions that are on the books that
would be filled but if we don't have the
business they are they are not filled
and and it's why there's the giant
discrepancy Giants long term
um in other because it's it's uh it's
money that we would theoretically be uh
billing people for those services and
and Graphics services
if you will is
um is down people are printing less than
they than they were
and and we uh we don't spend the money
if we don't know the business we're not
permitted to it is a it is an entity
that
uh Gary said to me you know we're going
to end the year in the black and I said
well that's good because legally we
can't end it in the red
um
in a nice way but it's um uh so there
are there are uh there are positions
there that are
um 100 other funds and that are just not
filled and almost certainly will not be
filled but suddenly people start
printing stuff they would be filled so
if we cut down that area it really makes
no difference to to anybody right it
probably wouldn't yes it also it's also
not General funds
okay
um Public Works
um
uh Public Works we build things uh we
oversee building things
um
vacancies uh create a lower spend here
this is a this is another area where
um about
um about a third of their budget is is
billed out so to speak for by project
um typically capital budget projects but
they're Associated other projects
generally funded projects are not billed
out they're funded just funded
um we're in the process of developing a
new model and and looking at this public
works is um because of the difficulty
hiring engineers and Architects and
engineers and architects who are who are
project managers as opposed to
sort of academic Engineers or Architects
one of the things that we we want to
experiment with and and we're going to
and and I'm nodding my head in an odd
way at Karen behind me
um and looking on smaller projects we're
going to experiment a little bit with
how we uh how we manage a project and
and part of that is is related to is the
state a general contractor
there's a state not a general contractor
the state her is a consultant on the
front end of a process as a project
manager who's also an engineer or an
architect in the middle of the process
and then has has clerks who do the who
do the oversight on on the back end in
addition to that some of that is
replicated at agencies what we want to
do is is find a way that can uh make
things happen faster and and alleviate
some of the burden on a small staff
when the number of projects that must be
overseen are going up dramatically in
large part because of our phones and
this is an area where the state has
historically insisted
um going back for decades
um of oversight by a central unit it
actually oddly goes back to the only one
of my predecessors who went to jail went
to jail in the 40s or at least I know
about when going to jail
he went to jail in the 40s
um for uh when we had Public Works
before it was taken away from us and
then later given back for mismanagement
of a construction project where
basically he basically well
he let the manager do whatever he wanted
and then there was so there were some
Financial irregularities that might have
accrued to the benefit of his own bank
account
and that apparently was frowned upon at
the time
so
probably is now as well
that's where we so um because of that
we have an enormous vacancy rate here
and one of the things I would like you
to consider doing and I realize this is
another ask is allocating so we we
unfunded positions to the tune of 400
000 a year
and I would like you to consider
um
um giving us some of that as in a
consultant line the state hires
consultants and the state has staff or
lack of Staff right now to do the same
things and we'd like to use that as part
of an experimentation process
to find the better way to do things
that's Public Works
I'll also note that they will be the
ones Who oversee the garage
I have a question represent ylr
relevant to what we're doing in
Rockingham County where we're
going to put a 63 million dollar office
building up
and one of the Commissioners says we
need to hire a person to oversee it
and some of the others say no no we got
people on staff well we haven't put up a
big building in decades
and well we'll let the the contractor or
the oh the architect
and and I'm thinking no that's not a
good idea it's always a better idea to
have someone that's not part of the
architect not part of the building
business that works for us that does it
on a full-time basis and so I'm
supporting that Commission of the other
two are not
convinced but I think I would use the
example of the way you do it for the
state
always would have someone
that's specifically working for us
I I think it's I think it's very
important and you know Karen has a team
and we you know we do a lot of the
construction I'm not a lot of other
agencies to do too obviously but we do a
lot of construction and um you know
there'll be somebody with Public Works
who has a very centralized attitude
they'll also be
um you know one of Karen's staff who is
who is you know dedicated depending on
the size and scope of the project to
that project as well from uh from a
management oversight standpoint you know
you don't want to reach the point where
somebody says hey where are the garage
doors oh we didn't think you nearly
needed those
and that and it sounds silly but little
weird things happen all the time in the
in in construction where where people
make operational decisions based on what
they think you want
as opposed to how you're going to use
your house and it's usually might be a
team rather than a person because
especially if someone's over here making
sure that concrete passes the slump test
and someone's over there making sure
that the steel beams are put together
right and it can't be two places at once
while all this poor is going on so
sometimes you got to watch it
continuously and inhibit okay so we'll
talk a little bit about
as well about kind of how we how we
ensure quality control
um so so currently we we have a lot of
capital or capital-like projects
happening I think
probably 40 to 50 right now in my
division
um between arpa funded things Capital
funded things and and operating fund
funded things
um and a lot of those go through public
works as as the commissioner was just
talking about but we always have someone
on our staff that is very familiar with
the building so somebody that either
operates the building or is responsible
for that building in some way that
attends all those construction meetings
um and it it
Works hand in hand with the public works
assigned project manager to make sure
that all those things that we're just
talking about happen
um and and with arpa happening and with
the additional throughput of projects
happening within our division we we have
some
um a couple of folks that are just
dedicated to project management all the
time that's all they do
um is there anything else specifically
you want to talk about okay
thank you
not that we're offering to help
Rockingham County
um okay that's Public Works uh
Enterprise application management this
is a division that used to be called fdm
it was called financial data management
um
and the staff at some point said to me
you know that's a stupid name we don't
just manage financial data we manage the
state's entire Enterprise application
would you mind if we changed our name
and so in the last budget I think we
changed their name
um and it so New Hampshire first is the
state's enterprise system it manages all
of our functions it's the structural
backbone of state government it manages
you know everything HR payroll Etc it's
how we pay people it's How We Do
finances it's how we do everything
um that system this is a this is a unit
that does this they have had some hiring
challenges although they are
uh they do yeoman's work and they've
done a good job a couple of couple of
people left very quickly because they
got 100 remote offers a couple people
stayed
um which is a good sign
um and uh and they're very good people
um
we're there looks like they went down
but that's because the doit budget used
to be centralized here and has now been
spread across divisions um as it as it
ought to be
we received a 15 million dollar approval
from fiscal for arpa funds and from the
council
to start a major upgrade of New
Hampshire first
New Hampshire first is the state's HR
System it's the state's Finance system
and it's time to upgrade it and and as
you probably know the state has three
choices in this we could do nothing
um which is which was the old-fashioned
tactic of the state which we did 20
years ago we didn't at some point we
didn't upgrade right time for an upgrade
and someone went oh geez let's just not
and we didn't and for 20 years we had
and then eventually you know at some
point the only guy I left who runs the
system retires and you have to you have
to upgrade so we did a huge upgrade
actually in two phases of the system
so the current system we run is run by
infor so we can either so we're not
going to do nothing
um Dennis Goulet hates it when I say one
of our three choices is to do nothing
because that's not really a choice I'm
like I know but it's a choice we've made
before
um so the two choices are completely
re-procure and develop a new system or
to do a significant upgrade to the new
system
now is the time for this because it's
you know moving from on-premise to cloud
and it's a dramatic change in their uh
life cycle system instead of they're
moving from v11 to Cloud Suite so it's
not a number now it's a name it's like
it's like when Windows goes from it's
not a 3.1 to 3.2 it's a 3.1 to Windows
95 kind of thing I might be dating
myself
um anyway that's that's a major thing
that you'll see coming through in our
division over the next
um well over the next two years and it's
going to be a significant point of pain
risk and benefits is our is our next uh
division page 122 to 127
um
this is half our budget
it's interesting it's not that many
people but it's half our budget and it's
half our budget because this is where
retiree health is
um
it's a very well-run Division and I
would say that even if Cassie isn't the
one who used to run it but
um
I think we do a really good job here
it's it's it's workers comp it's
insurance and it's for in its retiree
health I'm oversimplifying a little bit
retiree health is the thing the Marquee
item I think is the right phrase health
benefits yes and uh oh yeah and health
benefits I'm sorry good Lord
um the health benefits plan for the
state which which you know is a 300
million dollar plan right this is an
enormous operation for the state's
safest how self-insured we don't just
hire an insurance company and we do we
do a very good job we're routinely
talked to by people who think well you
guys do that really well well we do we
know what our mission is uh and we hit
it so you can see in the budget here
that retiree Health has the large
portion you can also see that
fiscal 22 actuals 52 fiscal 23 adjusted
authorizes 67 in that line and and
probably at some point you look at that
and go huh
um did I anticipate something
um if you flip to the next slide we can
talk about this
um this is an area where I think it's
very important for our department that
we take a Victory lap and we did before
um
um I'm gonna I'm gonna have Cassie talk
about retiree Health
um
because she has a lot to do with it but
the trend line was very bad and we've
had some very difficult discussions
budgetarily in the past but if you look
on that graph at the at the first four
or five years there's an upward moving
trend line and we changed it and we
changed it by doing the right things
about leveraging federal funds in ways
that um created a ridiculously sized
wind to fall in this area
start by saying that in 2016 and 2017 um
some of the committee members were
serving at that time and we really had a
crisis we had a budgetary crisis where
we found ourselves a 10 million dollar
deficit for retiree health and so we
worked over a series of years to change
the law about
um and contributions that retirees are
required to pay toward the cost of
retiree health benefits and for the
first time ever we implemented a premium
contribution for Medicare retirees
um and we changed other certain elements
like co-pays and that kind of thing but
we were also looking ahead and
strategically considering well what are
the bigger things that we might be able
to do that could achieve some real
savings and if you look at 2019 through
the rest of the um the years there you
see Medicare Advantage Cost Containment
and that's really the big one and by the
way when we say the big one we also are
worried that it may be our last one okay
but what we were able to do was take the
medication the medical portion of
Medicare
retiree benefits and move from a
self-insured plan to a fully insured
plan and in 2019 we did that with anthem
and literally what we were identifying
this as a strategy but we were waiting
for the Medicare networks to catch up
here in New Hampshire and the minute
they did we met with Anthem and we
amended our contract and and and fully
ensured that that medical piece and what
it did was bring in federal funds and
that federal funds helped to offset our
general funds and that's really the
strategy and that's what you see here
with the savings so in 1920 we stayed
with Anthem and that reflects our
contract Amendment and then we went out
to bid and
um which was uh unusual for us we we
separated out the Medicare piece and we
changed vendors for the first time in I
don't know 15 plus years we moved to
Aetna and they actually bid zero dollars
for the premium for our Medicare Medical
Services we we continue to have
self-insured prescription drugs by the
way and so why did they bid a million
zero dollars and it's because it's it
works for us and um it's because they
they were betting that the federal
subsidies that they got were enough to
to meet their needs and and
um so it's been actually a very valuable
relationship and so we continued to take
that Medicare Savings and you could see
we did a little better it's it's also
really important to say that
um in 20 you start having covid and what
happened there were changes in how
people's behaviors about going to the
doctor getting medical procedures Etc in
in in health benefit world we call that
good experience so we've had good
experience but um that experience has
jumped this calendar year particularly
when you look at 2023
um that that's our budgeted amount right
so we're waiting for our our final
expenditures to come in and we expect it
to come in what did we say yesterday
about 10 maybe 10 10 million ish um uh
lower than we budgeted and and but but I
I think it's kind of important it goes
back to I think we've had our last
rabbit coming out of the hat that if you
even drop your 23 10 million ish you you
can see that upward trending costs and
and that's because inflation is hitting
health care and in prescription drugs
just like everywhere else
it's a big thing
are the number of retirees also
increasing
they they are we have
um our 13 500 now so
um so and and I think covid did
accelerate the the rate of
um retirements by state employees
um and uh you know for your information
I think one of the things that you don't
necessarily see in this chart but is
that the legislature since about 2009
has been looking at the eligibility for
retiree health and um and began to close
the door and tighten that up and so that
um it used to be that you would have to
have only 10 years of State service well
now you need to have 20. and um then
they um they they I guess I guess other
things that we did like increase the
premium contribution for the
non-medicare we found a lot of spouses
left the plan and that was likely
because they had other coverage right so
we I think we've done everything we can
to really tighten up the eligibility
I'll note that the under 65 retirees or
non-medicare retirees have have declined
for a few years we we think it's flat
now because we think most of that's been
teased out but it's a smaller number
it's a more expensive group The over 65
retirees continued to tick up and and I
think will but um think of it as
something like don't hold me to this
number but something like three percent
a year in terms of number
yeah and and those those under 65
retirees are delaying retirement because
people are right and um and the Medicare
retirees are about a third the cost of
the non-medicare retirees and that's
because of the federal funds that come
in for Medicare
good
next Friday we have a number of
retirement bills coming up that you
might want to pay attention to or
they made it through the house the last
couple of days okay
oh great okay we will watch for that
um I'm gonna
I'm gonna finally and I know you're
asking is he ever going to shut up um
planting property
um which in your book is Page 71 to 107.
it's a lot of pages
before we run back there I did have a
question since we're on 127. you show
like about a 17
number increase in employees if you go
to the bottom of 127
the authorized is the 11
and we're looking at perhaps as many as
328 have you been assigned like is that
part of the not digging back but housing
appeals board and other things no it's
actually that's not it's not them or
anything like that this is all us and
it's
um it's like we've ticked a couple as we
went through the presentation three of
them are new full-time positions one is
a purchasing administrator we talked
about one is the HR coordinator a dop
and the the other actually we'll talk
about in this division is an
environmental health and safety person
at in plant and property which
seems like something we ought to have
um the other there are 12 that are
conversions
and um and there are a couple things one
is the you know the peak card
administrator has been a class 20 has
been a class 59 position instead of a
class 10 position instead of a regular
and it's the pcard program is not
temporary not like it's going to go away
um our our Surplus uh our Surplus people
the the guys at uh White Farm you know
one is a full-time
permanent employee and he has a
full-time temporary full-time temporary
is a misleading name and say government
but you know they've been in the
position for a lot of years I'm about to
give the one guy a longevity certificate
and um next week I think and it and so
that's a that's a conversion as well
there's a conversion Steve in the mail
room is being converted
um just to give you an idea I'm like oh
Steve isn't and they're like no I'm like
oh okay
um and then one is the Paid Family Leave
position started out as a as a extra
budgetary thing so it's a 59 and now
it's in the position then in plant and
property one of the things that we're
doing
is we're taking we have an enormous
vacancy rate among building service
workers
52 or something like that
um and they're just nearly impossible to
fill we've taken a whole bunch of
part-time positions and
um are converting them to full-time
positions we're doing that initially
with a class 59 but we've been able to
hire
we've been able to hire at a full-time
position I mean that's just um that's
not really a surprise that's a market
thing
um and so we want to do that with seven
of those positions and we're basically
going to take what would have been class
50 money and so to be fewer people but
right now there are fewer vacant
positions we can't we're having trouble
hiring could you just put like a
one-page sheet together we can do that
when somebody asks that question sure
I'll do something and it'll probably
look something like yeah that'd be
perfect yeah just so when the question
is asked is someone well you went from 3
11 to 328 absolutely so when you convert
two part-time
yeah shoot part-time to full-time you
add a lot of benefits right and that's
why it's you can hire whereas otherwise
you can't yes yes that's exactly why and
it's and it's there's a lot of cost then
I don't think it's two to one I think
it's
that's four to one because of that
whatever all right thank you so we're so
financially
we're it's a zero sum for us and because
of that
yeah I mean it's you know the state went
you know State went up and down on on on
part-time cleaners and full-time people
won't remember but the 80s and the 90s
and we experimented five different ways
and was Contracting out and that's not
the contractors can hire anybody either
um but um
uh and we're in a point right now where
where part-time doesn't work if it does
it's it's a lot cheaper but it we can't
get them
okay so plant and property is
it's just I want to re-emphasize what
what the commissioner had said is that
when we did the conversion from the part
time to the full time we got rid of that
part-time budget so we made sure that
was a budget neutral we didn't add any
any dollars even though the position
count grew for those
thank you that's helpful
um
so most of what is in this slide I said
but just important we manage a lot of
buildings there are more than 90
buildings across the state including all
the courthouses
um more than four million square feet of
Office Space
and and I like to say the inside the
outside and the underneath
of those office spaces some of the
release buildings we have a
responsibility there the underneath
matters because that's where all the all
this stuff happens and
um and there's a lot there's a lot that
goes on there we also do Statewide
Energy Management as people probably
know
um but it's a lot of work it's a lot of
buildings and in some basic way it's it
it is what touches everybody every day
every state employee
um goes to work somewhere and they and
they you know here and that window
breaks one of Karen's people's coming
over to take care of it uh the new
safety administrator environmental
health and safety officer position
um that's created instead of uh catches
catch can I think it's important we have
a lot of people doing a lot of work on
Old equipment and buildings we have a
responsibility to
them and ourselves to be safe
um
Granite Place presuming we buy it and
frankly even if we don't even even if
it's leased and then Hall Street there
are positions in here for if we buy that
building there has to be a maintenance
person as well we own a building there
has to be a maintenance person I
remember I said to the governor's office
at one point the governor's budget
director said what do you want that
position for and I said well if you buy
Hall Street
we need we need a maintenance guy if you
don't buy Hull Street we don't need a
maintenance guy and he went oh I get
that
so that's that's kind of where that is
um I'll talk a little bit about
utilities and deferred maintenance
um because I think there's something
people want to talk about and then
there's money in fiscal 25 for what we
refer to sometimes as the Manchester
property
because I think once the facility moves
it's not the synonym Center anymore I
don't know what I'm supposed to call
that thing anymore right but that thing
the what used to be YDC
and if it moves out the property will
still be there and and most of the bills
end up transferring the maintenance of
that property which is currently with
that staff to us so there's money to
make sure everything doesn't burn down
and turn into well frankly Laconia
um if you know what I mean
thank you Mr chairman commissioner when
we were discussing
building the
parking garage over here
the architect that seemed to be
listening more to Concord than to us
said well we've got to have 20 percent
more space for the Attorney General when
we're moving him from that building to
this new building is he getting 20
percent more whoever it is getting more
20 percent
more space
I don't know it depends how you count
does it Karen not 20 it is it is more
space because of the functionality
issues with you know their basement and
their the offices that
um they currently have 50 something
thousand square feet and I think they're
going to be at about 61 000 square feet
so it's a little more space it's not
dramatically better than they have today
it's ten percent basically the Attorney
General said to me I don't want to go
backwards he said I don't want to be the
attorney general who moved us out of
downtown into into space that isn't
downtown and is worse and I suppose not
I said it's not going to be worse and
there's some ways it's going to be
better they have some offices today
where the walls aren't real walls
they're
you know the partitions that form
cubicles and you just send them to the
ceiling and we call it a wall they're
that and the new walls aren't going to
be like that so thank you it's better
not a lot better though it's a state
um so I'm going to talk uh I'm gonna
explain the big change we made here uh
on on two in two slides before that I
want to talk about utilities because uh
those of you on fiscal are going to see
you are going to see a request we're
coming back for um
uh you know there's a provision in every
budget that if the money isn't
sufficient to pay utilities because
something happened let's just say with
electric rates
um that we would come back to fiscal
you're probably going to see an item you
saw one last year for just under a
million this is going to be over a
million something like one five and it's
because when we set rates um
the last few years have been very unkind
to electric rates
and those paying them and so we're
coming back with that the state the
state pays something like 11 million
dollars a year in electric in utilities
and and we're going to be about 10 short
and um
and I can explain to you why if I can
bring my Unitil bill in and show it to
you and I think you can probably explain
why too
not
um
not great right this is what I'm
thinking to myself I need to I need to
invest in a wagon wheel or something
um deferred maintenance one of the big
changes you made a few years ago is
creating a maintenance fund for us and
it's it's a 75 cent a square foot charge
on on uh on the the rent like charges
that we charge other agencies
um to create an essentialized fund to do
maintenance that's not capital budget
and that isn't your you know regular
operating you know elevator maintenance
contract for extinguisher contract and
whatever you have left over but is roofs
and Carpeting and um you know equipment
needs when they come up but doing the
across the system doing the work that
needs to be done as opposed to the work
that there happens to be money for
I mean in truth if you think about the
building dra is in versus the building
that education is currently moved out of
the one is really nice and has fewer
maintenance needs the others dump it has
a lot of Maintenance needs and there's a
point at which it's not completely fair
to
let the one group off scot-free that's
deferred maintenance and that's where I
would put if you gave us a 3.6 million
dollars and then I'll be fast on Central
facilities Bureau representative hatch
as a question oh sure on that
maintenance fund and like I think you
just answered my question is that
sufficient that 75 or is that
never sufficient I mean the truth is
this the state has you know what I mean
the state has 500 million to a billion
dollars in deferred maintenance needs
and we don't we don't track accurately
because there's no point right and um
because you're going to do a million or
two million a year you have to make sure
you get the get the big stuff and you
know if you if you give me 100 million
dollars I could figure out how to spend
it I don't think we have the staff but
um we could figure out how to spend it
so it I think it's I think it's a good
number I think it's a good number for
for its purpose I'm just thinking in
terms of critical need no and it it I
think on an ongoing basis um that's a
good number to use I think that if you
have one-time expenditures you're you
could make I would put a one-time
infusion of um I think we asked for 3.6
into that fund and and I think it's good
and I think it's actually a good place
for things like that to happen so your
slide shows 2.6 but yeah well then I'll
tell you the numbers
yeah I'm sorry uh fiscal 24 2.6 and then
an additional 1 million in fiscal 25 for
a total of three six
um but that can be scalable and it can
also depend on what year to put it in so
okay I'm sorry I didn't read all the way
across
thank you
thank you Sherry good catch
um so we created a central facilities
Bureau why we budget most of this
division by accounting unit by building
you'll notice that most of the
accounting units are building some of
them are multiple buildings some of them
are all building and there a lot of
costs are done on the basis of a
building right there's a utility bill
most of our utility bills are for one
building
um or are easily separated out by a
building and and and the work is done by
a building but a lot of the staff costs
and some other costs don't really
function that way and never have and so
what we used to do is a sort of odd
approach and I used to say this I'm
going to use the names of people who've
all retired because it's easier
um
Ron White was the highest paid person in
the Bureau of General services so we
budgeted him in 29.50 which is the
largest accounting unit because
salary biggest accounting unit
second biggest salary we budgeted that
guy in the second biggest accounting
unit which happened to be 29 Hayes and
drive because you know that kind of
works and you and we would do that and
so there'd be a building where it looks
like they have no maintenance staff
was because the guy sits in the building
next door and so the one building pays
all the costs and the other pays none of
the costs of that guy and it looks like
nobody does anything there
it's a rough
vague easily administered tool that was
okay
but it's not accurate and it's not right
and it and it does not reflect how we
actually do costs so uh so Karen and
herself spent a great deal of time
unfortunately for them trying to figure
out this and they created a central
facilities Bureau which is where the
centralized charges some charges are
easily centralized some are easily
allocated to a building utility bill is
the best example and as opposed to an
electrician who works in 25 buildings
and his cost should be amortized over
that so we created that unit and uh and
the cost will be will be allocated that
way as a central expense it makes it
look like this division's budget went up
eight million dollars but it didn't
the chart on page
20 whatever page has a chart kind of
explains how this works
and that
um
I use a couple of a couple of examples
we use labor and revenue just because
they happen to be two agencies that are
in their own building
and so
you know if there's a there's an
accounting unit for Spalding
and the what happens is we take the
actual expenses for Spalding and we Bill
labor for them they then pay Das as a
line in their budget for Tran I think
it's actually listed as transfers to
General Services we might have changed
the name of that
under the new model what will happen
though is that that accounting unit will
also
uh uh there'll be a similar transfer
between the central facilities Bureau
and that accounting unit so that then
those Central facility costs are also
allocated to that accounting unit and is
then billed to in this case the
Department of Labor and that's how this
will work it
it I know it might seem a little bit
complicated but it's good accounting
and I'll leave it at that
she's the accountant
um
on page 75 and 76
of your handout so um your actual budget
book 75 and 76.
you'll see the central facilities
account which happens to be 15.89 so
once again that's on the takes up most
of 75 and a little bit on 76.
and so what you'll see there is that
you'll see all of those shared costs of
about 8 million each year most of that
being personnel and so as as the
commissioner had stated those costs are
for a lot of the workers that are shared
amongst all the buildings they'll get
allocated based on the work that they do
and get billed to those appropriate
entities the next what you'll see at the
very bottom of that page is it says
intra agency transfers of 8 million and
then the the grand total on the next
page will show net funds zero so once
again while it looks like total
Appropriations have gone up 8 million
for the Department there's also an exact
dollar for dollar Revenue that's coming
in from those agencies that we're going
to be billing so I just want to point
that out because you know you
you tend to focus on that sort of spend
line and this is one where it's a net
zero transaction
um when you look at it in total
you think about your budget there are
two two areas in the budget where where
there's sort of quasi-double billing
doit costs which are allocated every
agency and we pay the oit so it shows up
twice and frankly our plant and property
expenses and this is a sort of a sub
double billing whatever that works out
to be
here so if my quick arithmetic is still
any good
is about a six million dollar new ask
over what the governor had supported I
think we've got
the three new positions and purchasing
and deferred maintenance that's arpa
contract Service I'm sure your math is
right oh I I don't know maybe it sounds
too good then maybe I should check it a
little further
so we have that Mr Hoffman those items
and that one sheet of paper showing the
why it's going from 3 11 to 328 or
whatever
okay good
I must see it in the right private
school or something
Mr Hoffman used to work for das so his
math must be correct well we steal all
the good people we can right we we try
to steal them back we we still Sherry
from the LBA
tonight
so I did have some questions but you
also have under your jurisdiction the
child advocate advocate for special
education in housing appeal board so
they're they're they're here separately
I'll go away and you can talk to them I
was just curious why they were assigned
to das especially like when you look at
child advocate maybe advocate for
special education I've been asked by
other division members oh I can explain
that entirely
um my this is my sense when the
legislature passes a bill
and something happens in it and there's
a loose end and they don't know what to
do with it
they assign it to us okay thanks
somebody somebody said to me once about
uh actually one or two of the the
um independent agencies
um
they said doesn't everybody just get
assigned to you
and I said well
yes but they don't have to
but I think uh I think we're used to it
and we're here to help
now although my understanding is they
have no staff so they're probably easier
and I could go to a boxing match not
that I enjoy boxing but well thanks
Charlie I don't see a need for you to
come back but thank you you know
um anytime we're right across the road
and I can come back you can come over
you can talk to a sub subset of us if
you'd like we're happy to help we'll try
to fit that six million dollar in but
again we don't really know yet so but
we'll try you know my somebody said to
me before the meeting we don't know how
much money we have to spend I forget who
that was
next Wednesday
in theory thank you very much all right
thanks
so someone from the child advocate
and once uh you get seated if you want
to state your name and if it's difficult
to spell for our Clerk
that would be good and maybe you could
ask my question uh
maybe you could answer my question why
you were assigned to das
oh so my name is Cassandra Sanchez I am
the child advocate and I have with me
Karen Kimmel from my office
um what I can share with you is we are
an independent oversight agency and as
an independent agency
we could not be placed under DHHS
because we oversee their services
um our office oversees All Children's
Services so we would not be a good fit
under the doe and that leaves for us to
be independent and impartial the best
place to put us was Das okay
my name is Cassandra Sanchez first name
c-a-s-s-a-n-d-r-a last name Sanchez
s-a-n-c-h-e-z
and I have with me Karen Kimmel and her
last name is spelled
k-i-m-e-l one m
we have some materials that we're
sharing with you as well I will go over
the Powerpoint slides that we have here
for you
um and I have some references to the
budget materials as well
but I did want to start and share a bit
about the office for those who may not
be familiar with the office of the child
advocate our role is to be an
independent impartial agency that
oversees Children's Services
initially when the office was developed
the oversight was specifically for dcyf
including their Juvenile Justice we have
since had an expanded jurisdiction as of
December 2020
and with that time frame we now with
with that new jurisdiction we now have
oversight over
DHHS child serving agencies other
executive branch agencies that provide
services to children and the provider
agencies that contract with them and
what that means is that that includes
our oversight over all of the
residential facilities that are now
contracted with the state they're
contracted through the Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health which falls
under DHHS we have oversight over that
agency and all the contracts they
maintain we have oversight over dcyf and
the contracts that they maintain for
Provider Services to families
um and it also would include in the
executive branch
doe with regards to Children's
educational needs and the goal of our
office is to ensure that children across
the state of New Hampshire's best
interests are protected at all times and
that we have services available to meet
their needs so in our oversight role we
spend a significant period of time
assessing and reviewing the Provider
Services that are offered to children as
well as those residential facilities and
sununa youth services Center
um we've been highly involved in in
discussions around the new replacement
facility and taking a look at the bills
this session my time is spent advocating
in legislature to governmental entities
as well as meeting with children and
hearing their concerns and needs and
ensuring that we are able to address
their concerns through complaints we
also work a lot with parents so one of
the documents that we have for you here
is our our fifth annual report and our
fifth annual report highlights the work
that we've done our annual year goes
from
October 1 to September 30th and so our
last year was October 1 2021 to
September 30th 2022 and that shares a
lot there's a lot of data in here about
the work that the office does
and so to get to our budget
needs
so in the slideshow
um the the slides that we have for you
here we start by sharing the mission and
the Mandate of the office the mission of
the office was updated in 2021 after a
strategic planning effort by the office
and so if you look on page six of the
annual report you can see some of the
highlights of the work completed by the
office
and the annual report also speaks to the
process of the Strategic plan which
would be on the following page page
seven but those highlights there are
just some touch points of outcomes
um of the office and how we have
influenced the lives of children through
our work again those are just highlights
that does not capture
all of the work that we do in all of the
children's lives that we are able to
impact through the work of the office
if you go to the following page on the
slide show page three we have the
overview of the office and this touches
on the specific we have some specific
numbers for you in the in a report if
you flip to the annual report page 15
you can see the complaints and inquiries
that come into our office so those are
direct Outreach to our office with
either an issue with the system or with
one of the child serving entities that
is working with a family or a child or a
provider and so in the past annual year
we had 319 contacts to the office
primarily those come in through phone
and email but we also have some
in-person contact and some of our
personal Outreach
um to the children where we will get
these complaints and inquiries and the
bottom there shows you who our primary
callers are which
um at this time it is parents and
guardians but we've made a great push
and effort to ensure that we're reaching
children as well and hearing directly
from the children
and if you go to page 17 it talks about
the incidents that are office monitors
so we received
2508 incident reports in this past
annual year that's a 31 increase from
the prior annual year and we do expect
that number to continue to go up
um the incidents it lists for you there
all that is included in the incidents
that we receive and as I mentioned with
our oversight over the facilities the
majority of those reports come from
facilities that specifically restraint
and seclusion reports and incident
reports from sysc
and what our office does is we review
all of those incidents and ensure that
children's rights are being protected
and that they are being kept safe in
these programs so we do review each of
those incidents that come into the
office which does require quite
a time commitment of staff to be able to
do that and as I mentioned we anticipate
that number to increase and the reason
for that is we are contracted with
out-of-state programs we have quite a
large amount of children that are placed
out of state because we do not have
enough New Hampshire programs to meet
their needs and when that happens for
children
um we we seek to get the same
documentation that we get for our
in-state programs including restraint
and seclusion reports we do not
consistently get those from all the out
of state programs at this time
and so with with the request from Bureau
of children's behavioral health for
contract compliance for the
the agencies to send everything to them
and us we do expect an increase that
request was sent out in November and
they are expected to begin sending them
this month and so we're not sure what
that number is going to look like but we
do expect an increase of those coming in
so to align with that additional work
for the office we had requested through
our Budget moving a part-time legal
secretary position to a full-time
position it does appear that that was in
the governor's recommended budget it did
include that the allocation for that
position and this would be a person that
would specifically work on entering and
reviewing the incidents and bringing any
of concern to my attention to address
with directly with the agency
I should know this question but too many
facts when were you established when was
your office established the office was
established in 2018.
so we are still we are still a young new
office
um I I was appointed to my position in
April as a second child advocate for the
state
okay wonderful thank you
[Laughter]
um so if you flip the page of the annual
report to page 18
um you can see our system review
mappings and so this is the work that we
do to influence system or change system
reform and change when they're when we
are able to identify cases of concern
with the agency so we did engage in
three last year and these are typically
cases um some of which may have been
highlighted in the media or cases of
severe severe abuse or neglect to a
child
um that our office felt required a
review of this the system as a whole and
so when we're talking about System
review mapping we're not talking about
just the dcyf system we're talking about
other systems that may have been
involved in the lives of that family and
how can we make recommendations for
changes to those systems to better
protect children in the future so we
don't have in such severe instances or
even potentially fatalities of children
in the future of New Hampshire
so those are critical to the work that
we do and and um
and the reform efforts that oftentimes
come in front of legislature to take a
look at changing state laws to better
protect our children
and page 19 speaks to our Outreach and
education
um so it notes Here facilities that we
were able to visit in person some of the
work that we did as well some some
quotes that we had in response to
different areas in which we visited and
we also attended some in-person events
to further engage children
as you'll see there we had at the time
ending in September 25 000 plus miles
driven by staff to be able to reach
children some of those miles also
include out of state miles so that ties
back to our budget and that
um
we
had in this year
um we had five thousand dollars in our
in-state travel reimbursement and eight
thousand dollars in our out of state
travel
um unfortunately we did not get as much
of that in our efficiency budget for the
following year so at this time it's
shrunk
I buy a lot for our office and
considering how much we've spent already
this annual year we do see that if we
are not able to get additional funds we
will not be able to outreach children in
the way that we have been
um in Prior years there was difficulty
with that in-person Outreach because of
coven but now with restrictions lifted
we are able to visit much more than we
have than the office had in the past
um currently out of the five thousand
dollars of our end state
um travel reimbursement we have 670
dollars left to get us through June
um and in our out of state travel we
have spent down about 3 000 and plan to
continue to visit additional
out-of-state facilities to meet with
children so ideally we would like to
add an additional 9 000 and out of state
travel and I mean in state I'm sorry
in-state travel additional 9 000 and for
out of state travel an additional 9 600
and so that would include there are
facilities that we have to fly to and
can't just drive to so that would afford
US the opportunity to be able to fly to
these facilities and meet with children
as we understand that those are some of
the most vulnerable children of our
state because they're not close enough
in close access for family to be
visiting on a regular basis for dcyf
staff to be visiting on a regular basis
so they are more at risk of abuse and
neglect in placement so we would like to
ensure their safety by by taking the
time to not only meet with them
virtually but spending time at the
facility in person
Melissa Mr Hoffman did you get those
numbers good thanks
representative hatch
thank you Mr chair
um thank you and thank you for the work
you do
um thank you on out of state or any
travel is there is there a pre
designated number of times you need to
reach out to the children are physically
interview them or see them is there uh
parameters that you have to stay Within
or is it it's not it's not at this time
it is at the discretion of the office we
do plan if a child is contacting the
office and asking to meet with somebody
that we do have a procedure in place
that we send somebody out within 24
hours as long as it's a weekday if
they're calling on Friday afternoon
um you know the following Monday to meet
with the child immediately to ensure
that they are safe so in those in that
instance that is the one procedure in
place otherwise for out-of-state
facilities we look at the highest in
need so we take a look at out-of-state
facilities that have the most children
placed there and those in which that
we've received either concerning reports
from either in-state or out of state we
do have Partners in um in some of these
states where the programs exist through
some of our professional organizations
and those Partners will highlight when
they're hearing concerns in their own
State about the program and that was
when we will prioritize going to visit
that program and ensure the safety of
our New Hampshire children because
oftentimes we find that those States
will know about the program the problems
in the program but it will not travel
all the way up to New Hampshire and so
we do we don't know necessarily that
there are worries about what is
happening in those programs
in terms of budgeting out of state
um what you're basing on the additional
mornings for or
um that's all just yes so we would like
ideally we would like to be able to
travel to at least three programs out of
state by by plane a year and this would
allow us to do that where others are
within driving distance there are a
number of programs in Massachusetts that
would be driving distance
um so we would not it would not require
the this overnight stay necessarily it
would not require flight in Vermont as
well which are in driving distance so
those are much easier to get to and and
much more fiscally conservative trips so
we do consider those as well but it's
the further out trips that we would like
to be able to increase
thank you
so I'm still way back looking at your
reports you know I haven't caught up yet
but obviously trafficking of any sort is
bad I see that there are a number of
cases of sex and work labor trafficking
how much of is that increasing or where
where are these people coming from that
are being abused and
it does appear that those numbers are
increasing um and speaking with our
partners that specialize in that area it
does appear those numbers continue to
increase
um it's often that we're finding it is
children that are in care that are being
trafficked whether they're running from
a program there are times where they
will elope from a program and then we'll
end up trafficked through that and
return to the program reporting concerns
for trafficking
um there are other times that children
are previously involved in trafficking
and then come into care and it's the
difficulty of creating barriers for them
and protection so that that relationship
doesn't continue but if the person knows
how to access them they do have the
ability even if they are in Care at
times thanks representative McGuire do
you have a question
so I'm still unclear as to
exactly what your department does
compared to HHS so I'm going to need an
example so suppose a teacher thinks that
a child is being mistreated
they call dcyf yes and then they come
out and investigate yes so where does uh
your agency get involved in this example
yes that's a great question so they
would initially reach out to the agency
the agency would go out and investigate
and for instance the agency says that
they've there's not enough for them to
open a case with the family that it's
not meeting the threshold of the law and
so they're looking to close out with
this family but there's additional
concerns that keep coming in and that
the school is contacting the agency and
it's not going anywhere and they have
real worries for the safety of that
child so ultimately a call would come
into our office from the school for
instance
explaining that they've attempted to
work with the agency to protect this
child they don't feel the agency was
responsive
then at that point we do have to ensure
that they engage with the Ombudsman out
of HHS so we would refer them to the
Ombudsman at HHS and ask them to call us
back once they've engaged with them and
whether their concern was addressed
oftentimes they will call the Ombudsman
they will call us back say our concern
was not addressed we have real safety
concerns for this child and we've spoken
to everybody within the agency and
nothing is changing and at that point my
office would get involved we have the
ability to directly sign in to their
system the DHHS System review any case
notes that they may have on that family
review any efforts that they've made to
address the concerns called in by the
reporter and if we find gaps there where
there are things that they may not have
looked into or there are instances in
which they did not follow policy for
instance they may have sent somebody out
to talk to the parents to ask about
specific abuse in the home but they did
not send somebody out separately to
speak to the child in a safe location
and so we would look at that and we
would contact the agency and say and say
per policy you are expected to meet with
a child separate from the family to
ensure that the child is safely able to
disclose any concerns of abuse in the
home that did not happen we need you to
reopen and take a second look at this
and further interview the child and that
is an example that I can say we've
absolutely engaged in those
conversations with the agency and that
is the purpose of our oversight is to
ensure that they are following the law
following their own policies and truly
assessing for safety of children and we
are finding with an overworked system
that that's not always the case and
they're overworked and understaffed and
we do acknowledge that but that does not
leave room for children to not be safe
and to not be assessed appropriately
thank you so in this example
you call them and say do better in this
case
um
if they don't that's the end of it or I
mean can you
can somebody get fired who should have
been doing their job and isn't or
so we don't handle worker discipline
that is handled within the agency it
would rise up to higher ups within the
agency to share recommendations to them
and what we found on the case because
they are not reviewing every single case
that's involved in the agency so we will
go all the way up to the director of the
agency and say this is what we're seeing
may go to the commissioner if it's not
going further and we also have the
ability to share openly with the public
or with the governor's office
as well as the legislature if there are
issues that we are seeing that are are
going unaddressed by the agency and
they're not choosing to follow our
recommendations
so what what fraction of the case
complaints you get do you just decide or
just
do you mean that we actually have but
now come on in the example you gave the
school called you
dcyf is not appropriately investigating
some case that's a complaint right yes
so what fraction of those and then you
look into it and you say
um maybe the complaint is not justified
or maybe it is right so in what what
fraction of the cases is the complaint
Justified
so that actually brings us to another
item on um in our prioritized needs so
if you flip two and I will explain the
connection in one moment
if you flip to page six on the slides it
talks about a case management system so
we do have a case management system
we use Salesforce and we have been doing
our best to utilize the system
as well as we can there are a lot of
difficulties in pulling the information
that we would like to be able to pull
out of that system such as outcomes that
is one that we are unable to track with
the way the system is currently set up
Salesforce was piloted with the state
and and we were offered the opportunity
to Pilot with them early on
um in 2018 so our office did that we at
the end of that pilot had a lot of
recommendations for changes to the
program so that it could better assess
the work that we are doing and we could
have better outcome data to share there
was no further work at that time and so
as you will see there in that history it
says in 2021 we worked with doit and Das
to release an RFI
and RFQ was released in 2022 to
determine an amount needed for our
minimal needs so our minimal needs to
get the program to a place where we can
better measure and share outcomes of the
office we need two hundred and thousand
dollars for a project that is the bare
minimum we were quoted mil in in the
Millions for some of the projects to
really
completely go through every aspect of
Salesforce and open it up and available
to us for what we need we are looking at
the bare minimum just to be able to get
this job done we've understand the
importance of the outcome data and
really want to be able to better capture
that for the agency as well because we
do bring them these cases to them on a
case-by-case basis but it would be much
more effective to bring it to them at
the end of the year and say this is a
percentage of cases that our office had
to intervene on and change had to happen
versus the complaints that we got we
cannot do that we have way too many
limitations with our system right now
okay can you say
what fraction of the complaints to dcyf
end up pushed up so that they become
complaints to you
um I died we don't have data that we
share with the Ombudsman office there
versus the ones that we get we do have
meetings with the Ombudsman office on a
regular basis at DHHS to talk about
shared complaints and we find that often
they have they've received the complaint
first before it comes to us there are a
few that we we do always refer to them
but we find that we have shared families
and shared complaints but we don't have
their data to know
and and even specifics of names of
families to know how many complaints
that they're managing that we also
received
I think
so I'm looking at the slides four five
and six all those prioritized needs none
of those were addressed by the
governor's office
one of those was
um the one in which that was addressed
by the governor's office is page five
and that is a legal secretary to go from
a part-time position to a full-time
position
where you show seven going to eight
that's that position yes correct
moving right along yes
so to the other position that's in the
prioritized needs is the public
relations representative and training
officer
so for our office it's quite important
for us to be up to date on Research
backing um Child Development so we focus
a lot on research and Child Development
a lot of research and on brain
development for children as well as Aces
studies so we follow research on a
regular basis and we we make
recommendations for best practice based
off of that
um that requires us to attend a lot of
trainings and stay up to date on the
many changes that are happening in the
happening in the psychology field
relative to Child Development
so part of our budget we do have have
funds as well for employee training that
was reduced down
um quite a lot so we are looking at
currently in the efficiency budget we
have one dollar we are looking at adding
additional two thousand dollars so that
we can continue training but with that
there is a lot that goes into organizing
the trainings for our office so we are
looking to add a position
uh for a training officer full-time but
as well as public relations
representative so another aspect of
reaching children in today's world is
having active social media our office
currently has a Facebook page we have a
Twitter page and we have an Instagram
we do our best with the staff on site to
update that on a regular basis to be
able to share what reports we're putting
out to engage the public and to to reach
children that way
with the limited staff that we have in
office and all the other complaints
um and incidents that we are reviewing
in the office we have quite limited time
to put effort into that but we fully
understand from the children that we
meet with that social media is where
kids spend the majority of their time
that's how we're going to reach them
that's how they're going to learn about
us and be willing to outreach us and we
also understand it takes multiple
attempts with children to get them to
engage with us so going out for children
in facilities is great because they are
there and accessible very easily but
when we're talking about children in
foster homes we don't have the same
access to being available for children
foster homes unless we have a
relationship with the foster parent in
that home where they may recommend the
child to outreach us but children who
remain in the community whether they're
in their family homes or whether they're
in a foster placement or whether they're
with an extended family member we are
not reaching that population and we
understand we're missing that population
and so that's a real Focus for us is to
to get to them and so this position
would address both we would be able to
have one position that would work dual
track on promoting our social media
and enhancing our connections to
children that way and ensuring that we
are receiving training that's adequate
for our office because there are a lot
of trainings that are offered some of
which through professional organizations
are offered for free but are they really
touching on the topics that we need to
be expanding our knowledge on and we
need somebody to take the time to really
weed through the many of trainings
offered to us and point out the ones
that are going to be most worth our time
and are truly going to benefit the
issues that we're seeing in the state of
New Hampshire because a lot of these are
National organizations that offer
National trainings but is that really
connecting to the issues of the children
in New Hampshire some are especially if
we're talking about mental health for
children there's a large mental health
need for the children in the state of
New Hampshire so all of those seem to be
quite relevant but there are other areas
of development that may be better
fitting for inner city children versus
children that that live in this
population and so we we would greatly
benefit from having a person to
um spend their time specifically on
those issues as well as being able to
bring in personal trainers to the office
we have had an opportunity to work with
um outside consultants and bring them
into the office to do training
specifically for staff and we find that
because of the work that we do they are
willing to give us a low and reduced
cost
um and so if we had somebody
specifically who was focusing their
efforts on making those relationships
and outreaching and explaining what we
do and explaining why we need their
expertise in our office we believe that
we will be able to get more of those
than we've had thus far we had one in
the past year and we'd like to see many
more
are there some additional questions from
the division members
all right you've given us a lot of good
information I am a little curious
why they basically zeroed out your
training line or put a dollar did they
someone expect you to get a grant this
or no unfortunately we had a a large
increase in our
um our doit expenses as well as our Das
expenses and with that increase we had
to pull from other lines and
um we there were certain lines that we
pulled some not all from but some such
as that line had to go down to zero to
be able to cover that cost
um so if you see with the
it's the um
transfer to oit and where's the other
one
okay yes 27 and 28.
um as you can see they drastically
whatever 28 went from
um the uh the actual expense in 2022 10
000 16 000 up to 22 almost 23 000. um so
quite a jump in expense for our office
and being a small office with a small
budget that that leaves us very minimal
options of where to pull that money from
to ensure we can cover those costs
um
so representative Hewitt do you have any
suggestions here
not actual not actual suggestions but
um perhaps you could Enlighten us to
send us something
pertaining to
the fact that you had to you had to
reduce a lot of stuff that you wanted in
your budget because of the expenses
uh could you prioritize for us anything
among the things that you cut
anything that you feel is very important
as far as the the work that you do so
that we can assess what the difference
is and and perhaps to save you some
money
absolutely I can send you something for
that thank you and we are we are hoping
to seek out currently our office is 100
General funds funded so we are seeking
looking to seek out some additional
options but being a very young office
we're really working to establish the
office first before we can seek out
additional funding streams for the
office to um to ensure that we can
establish some of this without having to
use just 100 General funds but we
understand that that is going to take
some time so we don't we do not believe
that that's going to be able to affect
the 2425 budget but we hope for the
next budget after that to include some
other funding opportunities for our
office
maybe the commissioner and his staff
might be able to help you with perhaps
seeking some assistance from somewhere I
know Charlie and staff are very good
about finding funds and making things
work and certainly doesn't make a lot of
sense to zero out your line for training
or travel basically
I know you need doit assistance but you
also need to be updated on training and
so we'll get that to Melissa Mr Hoffman
we'll see what we can do I think there
is some support for helping you a little
bit but again we don't know the final
numbers yet so
I
I don't see a need of you coming back
but again we might get a call and from
either Melissa or Mr Hoffman absolutely
happy to do so if needed thank you very
much and I will make sure that I can get
that together and send that to you as
soon as possible thanks thank you very
much
we're running way behind schedule
because everyone's provided so much good
information
so we have the advocate for special
education next
yeah I'm the advocate for special
education so again I'm curious why this
is with you
Senator Reagan is why Senator Reagan is
why Senator Reagan sponsored to build a
Creighton advocate for special education
and one day he walked into my office and
said
he said to Don is he here and I said you
know Senator Reagan and uh she's like oh
yeah he's right there and he goes and he
goes so I have this bill I'm attaching
it to you and I said okay
that's why
um I think he wanted it to touch
somewhere and he went you know childhood
Advocates attached to you so we'll do
that
um there's a placeholder budget here
it's in gets commensurate with the
legislation that was passed in 2023.
um if an advocate is picked before 2023
there is a there's a bill that
authorizes funds not otherwise
appropriated Etc
um I don't have any clue where that
stands I had heard two months ago that
they were close
and but that's you know rumor on the
street I heard they're going to pick a
they might nominate a special education
Advocate soon
and so that's all I know when they do
that we will work with that person on
learning you know when you're a new
agency and you start I mean you know God
helped that person right
um I gotta start but it's about so it's
about 350 000 a little bit more than
that and um and that's what the
legislation said so I think it the the
budget contemplates about two people
an unclassified
question yes well these people will
start with two you see what happens so
commissioner I see that the budget
uh there's nothing of course that was
authorized for 22 and 23 but again I
looking at the justification for the
359 thousand dollars in this budget when
I guess nobody is there and
so um
so the bill passed quite some time ago
and and in the bill for the but it
passed off budget right and so in the in
the legislation that created it they
they suggested a a budget of about 350
000 dollars
um for that and so let's say an advocate
had been picked
in uh like three weeks or six months ago
they would have been able to go to the
funds nonetheless appropriated for about
350 000 and we'd have done it through
something with boa I don't remember
exactly but Cherry would call somebody
upstairs and they would do a budget and
so we basically said Okay if that budget
had happened and they had had somebody
this is what it would be and so that's
their Baseline
so right now no person no office and
350 000 plus or minus in general funds
what I what I really think will happen
is that in one of the next two or three
executive Council meetings the governor
will nominate an advocate because I I
know there was a committee established
and they took resumes and they were
looking at people
so they'll pick somebody then when that
person is picked
um you know on that Wednesday I'll go
over and see them and say hey
congratulations
um here's what we're going to do now and
we'll find office space for them and it
depends when they get picked where they
might go
did you folks flag that for us keep that
in front of us
representative McGuire I think is a
question yes so you heard the child
advocate yes
I did most of it all right so to me that
sounds very duplicative with this HHS
ombudsman
in this case is there a special ed
Ombudsman at Department of Education to
handle complaints or not
it's a really good question I don't know
I know that there are external agencies
where you know let's just say you have a
a child in the system uh who has a IEP
or something there are places you can go
I don't know if the department has I'm
sure the department has something
and um
I was not privy to the debates on the
passage of the bill
when it passed a year and a half ago so
I don't really know what the
um what they think
the problem you should talk to education
about it though I would definitely this
is the problem I'm having I think the
previous one should be in division three
and I think this one should be in
division two and they can they can see
if there's duplication between these
different departments right so you know
it's only here because somehow it's part
of you but this is not really part of
you yeah okay no it's not really part of
me yeah
all right thanks I think you have great
instincts
representative hot I mean sorry uh Mr
Hoffman
small organizations
the housing appeals board we've got
that's another one
Commission on the Aging
thank you
I can talk about land stewardship
definitely
conservation land stewardship when OSI
was broken up what used to be oep was
broken up the energy stuff went to
energy the planning stuff went to
Bea I think and there were two leftovers
and it's two two very nice people Steve
Walker and
Charlotte thank you
and um and Charlotte who go out and they
inspect land it's when when elsip not
l-chip but elsip was created under Judd
Gregg and we bought a bunch of land
there's a there's a trust that is
related to walking the land I actually
walked the land one day something I did
um but um and they go out and inspect
and and that's where that money comes
from they also administer some
properties that are held in trust by
I believe fish and game and dncr it's an
office of two people they got a room in
Johnson Hall which is you know one of
our buildings that's kind of a dump and
um
and it's I don't mean in a mean way but
you know it's not one of our
pristine buildings
um and they they uh they go out and they
do land inspection and they do a good
job of it so it's a small program
I believe that somebody's here from
housing appealsport
S
I believe in housing and appealing about
that
state your name and if it's difficult to
spell for a clerk well I certainly will
my name's Elizabeth Fisher it's
f-i-s-c-h-e-r
and I'm here with Elizabeth Menard
and Elizabeth Menard is the clerk of the
New Hampshire housing appeals board and
I am the chair of the New Hampshire
housing appeals board there are two
other individuals within our agency
one is attorney Michael class
and the other one is a gentleman by the
name of Edward Rogers who is a licensed
land surveyor and
um engineer
we're a small agency that was formed
about two and a half three years ago
we just finished our second anniversary
of being in existence it took us a
couple of months to get set up we're in
Johnson Hall and we actually kind of
like it there
um it's coming to us plenty of parking I
guess that's one of the benefits of the
of being over there and our job is to
adjudicate disputes between property
owners and towns and cities with regards
to housing matters for zoning boards
planning boards historic district
commissions any of the other any of the
agencies or organizations and Boards
within cities and towns that manage land
use
um we are a parallel organization to
Superior Court and have all of the
authority that Superior Court has
um
except that we just deal with housing
issues and the legislature saw I guess
the wisdom in forming this board because
there were projects that were really
maybe should have seen the light of day
but could not get through the court
system the regular superior court system
uh in a timely manner and it was
impacting the ability for not only
Property Owners to
develop their property but also
um was impacting cities and towns to be
able to plan and and develop properties
that they'd like to to develop because
of the delays through the court system
so there's three of us we come with
specific expertise which I think is very
very helpful in these particular cases I
want to direct you towards our website
which all of our orders are posted are
decisions are posted and
um
we do that unlike Superior Court who
doesn't do it we do that for a couple of
reasons we want to do it for
transparency we want the cities and
towns and the applicants to understand
the nuances not only of those particular
cases but also of land use law and
processes within the state and I think
it's worked out pretty well from the
standpoint of people clearly understand
what it is that we have decided and how
we've come to the decision we are not a
super zoning board we're not a super
planning board we basically take What's
called the certified record and we take
a look at it and we have the individuals
the the applicant as well as the
defendant which in some cases is the the
city or the town or most cases the city
and town and we go through the entire
case and in some cases it shows up in a
one-inch binder and other times
Elizabeth has hauled up back boxes of
documents that have been tied to
particular cases depending on how
complex they are and we look at that and
we say did the city in town follow the
right regulations
uh did the developer
um prove their case or whatever their
issue was and I wanted to also mention
that it's not always a developer that's
before us in many cases I was looking at
some of our stats and in many cases
these are one-off Property Owners
they're trying to do an extension of
their house they want to put a garage on
they want to do an Adu which is a a
granny flat or a ancillary
um rental unit and for whatever the
reason is either the community doesn't
have the regulations in place in order
to do that or there may be some other
objections and so the thing doesn't end
up maybe being dealt with properly
within the city and towns because it's a
pretty odd issue
so you know I think I'm biased but I
think that this housing appeals board is
a tool that is available to the citizens
of the State of New Hampshire to try and
work through the um
issues around Land Development in their
communities
it's worked out fairly well
um
we have two hearings this afternoon
in which we will uh talk to the for
listen to uh individuals with regards to
whatever their particular case is so
representative McGuire has a question
yes thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you for coming
give us some numbers how many cases a
year what's your filing fee how many
gets settled before you even see them
that that kind of stuff well first I
have to thank Elizabeth because I asked
her in preparation for today's meeting
to go through our tracker and and
identify those since we've been opened
we've had 65 cases
in two years so these are lawsuits that
have been filed by applicants or a
Butters or whoever okay of that 11 cases
were either withdrawn or were settled
and I'm always pleased when one is
withdrawn now it may be that we've
already gone through the entire process
and we've had the hearing and we're
going to deliberate and make a decision
but then cooler heads have prevailed and
in the community they have recognized
that maybe they need to sit down and
talk to the individual that's suing them
to see if you can find a solution to
that within the community so I'm always
pleased when that happens and we've had
that happening a couple of times and
anecdotally have found that it is either
based on some of the previous work that
we've done and people have now
understood what their responsibilities
were and in some cases
it's just been settled and that's the
best place for these kinds of issues to
be to be handled is within the
individual communities
eight of those were appealed to the
Supreme Court
uh three of them have been heard by the
Supreme Court and they affirmed that we
got it right and so we were very pleased
about that
um I believe that there's two or three
that are in the process
um and then in March there'll be three
more that will go to have their original
hearings the challenge is if if either
party doesn't like the decision that
we've made within 30 days they have to
do a motion for reconsideration
and we may agree or not agree that it
should be reconsidered more often than
not we don't because we spend a lot of
time trying to make the original
decision
that preserves their right to go to the
Supreme Court and of that eight people
have eight eight cases have gone up the
challenge is that then they get in the
queue and it's often a year before it
gets resolved
and sometimes they're larger projects
and sometimes they're the one-offs that
folks uh you know want to want to appeal
um
so we're pleased that three have been
affirmed we're hoping that the rest of
them are
um
let's see
calculating around 1500 units have been
in play with these 65 cases and I
thought it was interesting when I did
look at the case tracker that
um you would think that there were a lot
of big projects and they're not I would
say a lot awful lot of our our cases our
smaller projects in in some cases two or
three units
or one unit
so that's kind of an interesting piece
um
cost 250 dollars
to come to us
if you wish you can come pro se
we've had I believe two or three cases
that have come pro se
the majority of them do seek counsel
and bring counsel to it and so obviously
if the applicant has their expense in
the city and town has their expense 99
of the time the cities and towns have
their legal counsel represent them
um
our process is very efficient from the
standpoint of you file a case tomorrow
within
um and then Elizabeth will send a notice
out to the city of town that says
greetings from the housing appeals board
you've been sued and within 30 days they
need to give us a certified record all
right and then within uh 90 days from
the beginning of that process we have to
hold a hearing
and there's a couple of things that
happen in the meantime
people will provide additional
documentation and then we have the
hearing and then within 60 days
following that we have to issue a
decision now sometimes that is altered a
little bit
from the standpoint of if there is
additional information yeah just I just
want to
slow you down a little bit so
um we have another bill to add a judge
in this area to to Superior Court
okay so 65 cases doesn't sound like so
has it been 30 and 30 or is it roughly
roughly okay so it's not that nobody
knew about you the first year and now
all of a sudden there's 50 cases the
second year or something like that you
know it's interesting the numbers
um kind of uh we reached we surpassed
our first year
uh before the second year ended so I
want to say about in November okay I
think we matched I understand you're not
sure but a little bit but not much okay
yeah so let me do you know how many
similar cases are going to Superior
Court or no we don't know how many
similar cases
um and part of the challenges is that
there's 10 Superior Courts
um and so you'd have to go and gather
that data from all of those individuals
Bureau courts and because it isn't you
know specified it's just part of the
spirit core docket so you literally have
to go through all that so I don't have
that information but the main advantage
is you are a few months versus could be
years it could be a situation
anecdotally we've heard that if you were
to file a case tomorrow listen to period
Court it might be seven months before
you uh get a hearing and you may end up
with a judge that doesn't have the
background with regards to real estate
law
um and that becomes difficult the
benefit of the housing appeals board is
you've got three individuals that this
is our career these are our careers this
is what we've always done and this is
what we know and so we think that the
product that comes out the other end is
better but since everybody has attorneys
there's there's not much money change
difference right the amount of money you
would spend going to you versus Superior
Court
probably about the same you don't know
um I can't to answer that question and
and
I can't I'm sorry I can't answer that
um we we tend to keep our proceedings
pretty efficient in that we have a
pre-hearing conference that we hold
about two weeks prior to our hearing
it's our hearing management conference
and aside from that everything's
primarily correspondence is exchanged
over email
so if your attorney's charging by the
hour maybe there's fewer hours or
something yeah yeah okay all right thank
you very much I believe I believe that
that they are
thought behind the legislation but in
all honesty
we're busy doing the cases that we're
involved with and and haven't calculated
that piece of it
I think I know where representative
McGuire was going because we do have a
bill that's before this division as far
as the additional Superior Court Judge
uh that would specialize in just land
cases selling planning cases to try to
speed up the process and just kind of
like a visual duplication
um perhaps with your board if that
particular piece of legislation moves
forward so you're almost entirely
General funded I see based on your uh
figures your other funds must be that
fee you charge the 250 dollars correct
yep and we're familiar with the um
representative Lynn's case excuse
that he's put forward with regards to
the land court and I've said to him and
would say to you as well that if there
was an interest for us to expand Beyond
housing and take on these other
components commercial
um
transactions and approvals and those
kinds of things then the New Hampshire
housing appeals board the have to change
the name I guess but um we certainly
have the capacity we also have the
expertise
are there any further questions on the
housing appeals board
Melissa Mr Hoffman anything
all right so are you happy with the
government Governor's recommended budget
yeah so we went through
um the numbers and there were some
adjustments that were made on the
governor's budget but we're assuming
that the information that
um created those adjustments is about a
ten thousand dollar reduction in what we
had originally requested
um we're assuming that those were
internal changes with ndoit and within
some of the other components because
those were the numbers that were
originally given by administrative
services so as long as it's a not a
situation that
um the oit is going to be looking for
you know additional funds
um we're comfortable with it okay we
would request that that information you
gave us as far as the number of cases
your fees like kind of a handout like
others have given us that you would
forward that to the folks at the LBA and
then we can reference it all right in
the future happy to do that all right
all right thanks so much thank you for
your time
thank you
so since the judicial Council can go to
fiscal you can leave now
thanks guys
all right I recognize a few characters
out there oh
sorry for the delay
um
we'll let everyone get settled and Mr
Hoffman the pass out your handout
thank you
the judicial Council for those of you
looking at 5 37.
I guess I better be on my best behavior
now that I see uh Nina Gardner has come
into the role
so if you could introduce yourself and
I can't remember if your name is
difficult to spell but if it is spell it
for our clerk I will do that thank you
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
my name is Richard Sam Peril uh it's
spelled s-a-m-d
p e r i l I'm the acting executive
director of the New Hampshire judicial
Council
um
the judicial Council uh is a state
agency with three full-time employees
the executive director and two staff
the council has a number of
responsibilities it's charged with
overseeing the quality
and cost effectiveness of the Indigent
defense program training and payment of
providers and certain child protection
and guardianship cases and engages in
Partnerships with non-state agencies
entities to provide other legal services
to children and to the poor I know that
most of you if not all of you are
probably very familiar with the agency
and what it does but I've included some
additional background information on
pages two and three of the handout that
you've received that would give you some
more information or someone who might be
new to the committee some background
here
the budget before you
represents the most significant increase
in the council's history
an increase which is necessary to
address an ongoing Indigent defense
crisis the judicial Council has
always taken its financial
responsibility very seriously and it's
past budgets I believe reflect this but
this is a time when this agency is at a
Crossroads and the services it provides
are in crisis
although funding alone won't resolve
these issues it's difficult to see a
path forward without that funding
the vast majority of the requested
increase is for court appointed cases in
significant part this reflects a long
overdue increase in the compensation
rate for lawyers who are handling these
cases and I'll talk more about that as I
proceed but this increase in
compensation was necessary to keep
lawyers continuing to take these cases
and provide the constitutionally and
statutorily required services in their
representation
the council is very appreciative of the
support that the governor and his staff
have demonstrated in supporting Indigent
defense funding as well as the Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court and the
rest of the Supreme Court in the steps
that they've taken in addressing the
Indigent defense crisis and some of the
articles that you'll see attached to the
handout I provided go through in some
detail and those are at the end of the
attachment those go through in some
detail sort of the history of what has
happened here in terms of uh Indigent
defense funding and the steps that the
court has taken to move us towards a
better place
I'll be talking more about this in
detail as we go through the different
accounting lines the judicial Council
has eight budget lines representing
various criminal and civil Legal
Services the council has a unique and
varied role with each of the individual
programs
and as I review the different requests
for services I'm happy to take questions
I welcome your questions
um as I go forward trying to give you
the reasoning that has been submitted in
support of each of these requests
the first one I'd like to talk to you
about is the request for additional
funding for civil legal services
this is Page 541 and 542 of the
governor's budget and Page four of the
handout that I provided to you
the council serves as the pass-through
for the state's commitment to civil
legal needs of indigent residents
through an appropriation through New
Hampshire legal assistance
additional funding for this would
provide funding for New Hampshire legal
assistances domestic violence advocacy
project
the devap was founded over 20 years ago
to provide civil legal aid to survivors
of domestic violence sexual assault
stalking and human trafficking
nhla attorneys represent survivors in
protective order hearings and related
family law matters
dbap staff work collaboratively with
staff at the domestic violence crisis
centers and the majority of the
survivors that they are representing are
deemed to be high risk individuals
people who are in high risk situations
that need additional help with
representation
they represent clients across the state
they can't accept every case with their
current Staffing but the focus is again
on survivors who are at the highest risk
the judicial branches
Representatives who are hates to
interrupt you but he has a question sure
so
um why is domestic violence sounds to me
to be criminal not civil
um so there are certainly domestic
violence prosecutions for people who
either violate restraining orders or who
commit assaults for example uh against
domestic Partners or intimate Partners
um what we're talking about here are
people who want to obtain restraining
orders because they're the victims of
domestic violence they're survivors of
domestic violence before
um either some sort of criminal process
has taken place or contemporaneous with
that process and so while certainly the
the criminal representation we'll be
talking about in a little bit covers the
criminal side of it here we're talking
about assisting individuals who need
protection need safety in the court
process where normally they wouldn't
have representation
to a restraining order is considered a
civil thing not a criminal correct yes
that seems weird okay thank you I guess
I should just uh and this is I if I'm
going too deep in the minutia I
apologize but uh in criminal domestic
violence cases there are bail orders
that also have attached to them a
protective order but it's a criminal
protective order there are what we're
talking about here are civil protective
orders that may or may not be related to
a criminal case
so if someone violated a protective
order then they're charged with a crime
correct okay thank you
um but uh and and I uh
you know in a criminal proceeding the
parties are the state and the defendant
so they're
um an individual who's actually been uh
uh subject to some sort of violence is
not represented
um
the judicial branch uh formed a task
force onto the domestic violence cases
in their report they noted that uh 15 of
survivors have representation and
protective order feelings that's a
fairly low number uh nhla is committed
to that crucial work they've received
Department of Justice victims of crime
act and violence against women act
funding they recently were awarded legal
assistance uh I'm sorry a victims Grant
um from and uh
under new changes uh to existing laws in
New Hampshire under and supreme court
rules paraprofessionals paralegals can
are authorized to appear with persons in
certain Court proceedings so this
funding that is being asked for here
would support the work of uh additional
attorneys and paralegals who are focused
on this kind of work and significantly
increase the critical representation for
them and for survivors of these cases
there's no further questions about that
I move on to the next item uh and talk
about the various items that are
generally fall under the area of child
protection
um
the casa line uh which is the governor's
budget at page 542 and the handout at
page five
this is a request for some additional
funding for court appointed special
Advocates and for Casa of New Hampshire
Casa of New Hampshire is the preferred
uh provider of gal services in the state
they're volunteers uh
our Advocates who receive extensive
training and supervision
there is a public-private partnership
here that consists of some funding of
that relationship so that children
whenever possible can be represented by
Casa advocates
in fiscal year 19 Casa worked with 52
children they'd handled 32 different
cases who had it to deceased parent and
then by fiscal year 22 that number
increased to 108 children in 72 cases
with deceased parents there are
volunteers spent an average in fiscal
year 22 of 262 hours per case and
conducted multiple visits in connection
to that
we really can't put a value on the
volunteers in their time the value to
the state the value to the children that
they serve
but of course uh in a finance meeting we
measure that value in dollars or attempt
to and if we were to apply current rates
that lawyers were being compensated at
and paid Guardians were being
compensated at to the volunteer time
that costs of volunteers have provided
that compensation would probably come
out to about eight million dollars
so uh the funding that we're asking for
here will be used to address certain
Workforce shortage challenges that cost
is facing the increased need that they
have for Legal Staffing and the very
important continued Recruitment and
Retention of volunteers for their work
representative thank you Mr I just like
to point out that on both of those pages
you're missing a zero I assume or or are
we going to reduce the amount in the
fiscal year I hope 2024 yeah I really
appreciate you pointing that out okay
just just some yes it's not confused to
be 75 000 it's 750 and then in in the
case of the casa thing it's two hundred
thousand you know I I knew I was going
to have something that uh somebody
pointed out I appreciate you noting it
and uh yes
um I mean as you can tell from the
governor's actual budget request those
are the amounts that we're asking for
thank you thank you
um the next item is non-casa gals this
is the governor's budget at page 542 in
the handout at Page Six
um these are private private Guardians
who were assigned when Casa is not
available
sort of it highlights
um the importance of additional funding
for Casa because of what a great
resource they are but when they're not
available
656 and that is
should be noted in the page six of the
handout that you have
so you'll hear me talk a bunch about
this but part of the reason
the reason that that additional funding
is necessary is because the rate change
for compensation that has been applied
to lawyers who provide services in a
range of cases has also been approved
and applied for Guardians who are
working on these kinds of cases and so
that rate has gone from sixty dollars an
hour to ninety dollars an hour and
that's part of the basis for our request
here for additional funds
no yes yes thank you so in Casa there's
90 000 hours how many hours are there in
this one
I don't know the answer I'm happy to um
try to determine that for you can we
divide 90 into some number what I can
tell you is that um Casa handles about
75 percent I believe of the uh cases uh
that require appointments accordions so
if uh we were to you know do some basic
math that means the other 25 percent are
going to these non-causage Guardians
headline them okay so if class is 90 000
hours these are thirty thousand dollars
is that I would agree with your math
okay and so
um are these the more complicated cases
or something the more difficult cases or
is or is it just random
um not necessarily I think
um you know
Marty sink who is um here on behalf of
Casa may be better able to answer that
but I I suspect a lot of it has to do
with geography and just a limitation on
volunteers yeah it's just a matter of
not having a volunteer available you can
actually take take the mic please
foreign
my name is Marsha sink and I am the CEO
of Casa of New Hampshire
so the when when we do not have a
volunteer available regardless of where
it is in the state we turn the case back
to the court and the court then must
appoint a paid Guardian at Leiden to
step in our goal is always to grow our
capacity to be able to be available for
100 of these cases
we're not there yet
so is this the
the Line This is a million dollars is
that
um page 539
our budget one 108.
our budget minus 542.
Caso said the governor's budget at 542
and
I believe and uh the web page what page
is that
5 30.
I I think so I'm sorry there's three
different
lines here that are covered under sort
of a a general Child Protection sort of
heading one is Casa okay one is non-casa
gals right and then there is a third uh
accounting line uh that's entitled
Guardian Ad Litem which is neither Casa
nor non-casa gals and actually covers a
wide variety of cases that uh include
guardianships and termination of
parental rights cases
and
okay so I haven't found I I see Guardian
El item a million dollars
so where is Casa is it non-counsel no
it's it's line 1101
um
it's uh
the 542.
uh non-casa right four hundred thousand
foreign
I'm happy to help direct you where you
you know to go if I can all right so
this is just the expense not for the
attorneys but
where it says non-cost of four hundred
thousand dollars
correct that's the correct line right so
is that just your administration of that
section as opposed to what we're
actually paying the attorneys for their
hours so here I just want to be so
Guardians might be attorneys but they
aren't necessarily attorneys um and this
is uh what is actually being paid to
them for their service it's not it's not
the agency administration of that it's
it's the actual funding for the people
who are going to court and representing
children
okay but costs of people are volunteers
they're not paid yes correct okay so you
said that this is a quarter of the total
number of hours
but it's a quarter of the total dollars
right so so there's something weird
going on
so
um Casa you know I'll defer okay in a
second but Casa has a variety of
different
funding sources certainly not
fully the state it's not funded by the
state
the non-casa gals are completely funded
by the state
so
[Music]
um
this would represent I mean really if
this is only 25 of what would be
necessary then there would be at least
um
12 1.2 million dollars necessary for
Casas and that's what Casa is spending
right and I mean at this time or last
year we were able to accept 75 of the
cases that came into the to the Circuit
Court on child abuse and neglect cases
the cases that we could not take get
returned to the court and then they end
up in that non-casa line in the budget
so we are constantly recruiting and
trying to grow the percentage of cases
that we were able to take
um prior to the pandemic we were at
about 89 percent and that has fallen as
a result of the of the pandemic and just
the shortage of volunteers we're
starting to see that turn around again
where there is more interest in folks
becoming Casa volunteers so I don't know
if that helps answer your question
so how many employees do you have to
coordinate these volunteers we our
entire um we have 39 well the equivalent
of about 37 staff paid staff and we last
year had over 500 volunteers who were
actually providing the direct service to
the court to our children
okay and and in the non-casa area
how many people are there
um you know I don't
know the answer to that because
um the judicial Council does not
actually appoint those people yeah we
only pay the bills
um so
um I could find that out for you if you
would like to know but uh yeah find out
more about like how many hours these are
eternities right and they're not always
attorney not always okay so yeah I mean
it's just you would think because one
side is volunteers there would be a huge
it'd be a lot cheaper
but on paper here it looks like they're
very close to the same
okay so that that's the issue
that I don't understand so maybe you can
get more details go into the details
sure I'm happy to try to do that for you
I I guess I'm uh
struggling here in the sense that
um you know the amount of cases that are
handled by Casa uh is
the vast majority of cases and uh but
they're doing it at a
they're mostly volunteers so they're uh
the benefit to the state is is
substantial there
um and yeah I think I would I believe it
but on the paper
the non-cost is four hundred thousand
dollars right the cost is uh 1.1 million
I I
I'm not sure where that number's coming
okay uh 542.
um I'm gonna if I can Mr chairman
um uh Nina Gardner who is a
the chair of the judicial Council uh the
council uh would like to offer some
input about this that might help okay
thank you
or just as a heads up I'm probably going
to recess this work session until
Thursday of next week
with the amount of material and again I
apologize that we ran so far over we
thought we'd have plenty of time with
you but we've got another work session
with the office of licensure at one
o'clock which is going to be very deep
and uh to say the least we got 300 Pages
there to deal with
um on what they want to do so Thursday
perhaps at 9 30 a.m would that work for
everybody and maybe some of those
questions that have been raised can be
addressed and then we can also
go into your handout which looks very
detailed which none of us have had a
chance to really dig into yeah
and then additionally because of the
amount of increase which is fairly
substantial before our eyes from last
year and a question I had could you also
get us a figure I believe you were
before fiscal at least twice for some
funds that keep you afloat what that
amount of money might have been for the
last year yeah and I I do reference that
in the materials okay I'm happy to talk
about that we actually we have had two
fiscal items approved and there are two
pending two pending okay
all right so Thursday at 9 30 a.m will
reconvene the work session and again I
apologize I I think even if we had an
hour we'd probably have to have you come
back anyway so
but thanks so much thank you
so again for the public we'll reconvene
this at 9 30 this next Thursday
and for now the work session is over
until one o'clock this afternoon
thank you
yes
here because we gotta deal with a 1092
positions
all right uh welcome to the finance
committee division one
are you Miss Courtney and Kelly
yes that is correct thank you
representative for the record Lindsay
Courtney executive director office of
professional licensure and certification
[Laughter]
yeah
sorry
absolutely so thank you um and with me
is our director of operations Heather
Kelly
what I'd like to do is start off by
doing a brief agency overview I think
some of you are very familiar with our
agencies some maybe not so much
um we are an agency that provides
administrative support to 52
occupational licensing boards councils
and commissions seven of those boards
are advisory boards meaning that the
agency has regulatory authority over
those professions with the advice of
those advisory boards the remainder are
independent regulatory bodies that have
their own
strategies policies procedures
directives and a different Mission but
we essentially support the boards in two
ways one of which is licensing
individuals and then enforcing matters
that come through either as complaints
or proactively through the inspection
process a couple of Statistics we have
over 200 000 occupational licenses
within our agency this varies
substantially
year to year depending on Workforce
needs for example we see Trends in real
estate when the Market's really hot that
we get an influx in applications
we've seen greater increases in
portability and applicants from out of
state so it does vary
we historically receive about 100
complaints per month that we manage on
behalf of the boards and we do conduct
over 2 000 inspections annually just in
four professions alone that have
inspectors
what I think is important to note from a
budgetary standpoint is that we are
fully self-funded agency and
core Supreme Court precedent our fees
have to bear relations relationship to
the expense that we are we are making on
behalf of the agency in other words we
can't really be utilizing license fees
to fund things that aren't related to
the licensure or disciplinary process
so if you look on page two this just
gives you a brief agency structure and I
think this is helpful because we have
recently undergone a restructuring of
the agency in the last budget cycle in
particular we restructured the agency to
reflect the two functions that we
perform so we have a division of
Licensing and board Administration
within that we have a Licensing Bureau
that really just processes processes the
licensing applications we also have a
bureau of board Administration those are
the Liaisons between the boards and
basically any other stakeholder
including the agency an internal
stakeholder and external stakeholders
we also have a division of enforcement
this was new out of hb2 of last biennium
and within that division we have a
prosecutions bureau which prosecutes all
of our cases in investigations Bureau
which naturally investigates the cases
and a compliance Bureau which is funded
by four professions that have
inspections or inspection requirements
previously prior to the divisions
creation
the complaints that were managed in in
cases that were prosecuted were largely
done by the administrative prosecutions
unit at the Department of Justice other
boards had a hodgepodge approach whereby
they may ask a board member to recuse
themselves to prosecute a case and then
cases went
on prosecuted so this division of
enforcement has really Consolidated that
approach and provided a streamlined
mechanism to ensure public protection
and then finally we have what we call
enroll because it's not a true division
as the office of the executive director
but it's essentially just all of our
operations including the provision of
legal counsel and you'll note that we've
split up the provision of legal counsel
between the agency and the boards and
the reason for that is because the
boards and the agencies at times have
conflicts
um and it is uh you know legally it can
become a conflict of interest to have
the same attorney representing both
parties that do not share the same
interests and you know I'm sure we'll
see that coming up with some of the
changes that are that are suggested by
the budget trailer
so if you turn to the next piece let me
ask a question yes certainly
representative I think so
um of these 1092 people
um I would assume that some of them are
specific employees of specific boards
right they're they're not sort of
general like like general counsel or
something like that no actually so of
our 83 authorized positions all of them
work directly for the oplc
um the statute actually uh grants and
directs the executive director to Super
rise and oversee all of this staff so
they do work directly with particular
boards but that's based on the needs of
the agency and the particular board
okay so maybe I'm looking at the wrong
line is that it
am I looking at General government is
1092 is that Mike is that what I'm doing
as opposed to oplc is at 83 yeah
yes I'm looking on page 190.
oh I see yeah yeah
okay my apologies thank you it's 89 I
guess is what you're 83 now 89 and then
correct Governor all right thank you
very much absolutely
foreign so moving on to the next page
which I think is Page Three
um
many of you know that oplc is a fairly
new agency we were established in 2015
um through that Budget Trailer
um
and I think for many years just kind of
continued to function as the boards had
previously functioned without any
administrative support from a separate
regulatory agency
but the role of the agency and the
boards is are different the role of the
board is to protect the public and the
role of the agency is really to ensure
that we're assisting them in in meeting
their missions in an efficient and
economic way
so over the last two years we've really
undertaken an analysis of where we'd
like the agency to go over the next
couple of years and Revisited our vision
and our mission and really our strategic
plan and what we would like to do over
the next 10 years if we could accomplish
our mission is really to transform and
modernize support for our licensing
boards as we know uh work licensing does
impact Workforce it is a barrier to
Workforce entry it's a purposeful
barrier to Workforce injury to protect
the public but there are many things
that we do in the office and that have
been done by the boards and previously
the board staff that are not necessarily
efficient and that are unnecessary
barriers to work for so we've we feel a
very strong need to really modernize and
transform the way we do business in the
office and it's going to take some some
time our mission as we see it is to
create a regulatory environment
favorable to Workforce opportunities
while protecting the public through
these efficient in economic processes
and we have four strategic goals over
the next two years which we actually
began this fiscal year the first is to
fulfill statutory and regulatory
requirements and that seems obvious
um an obvious goal of any agency but
we'll always say and I think a lot of
the LBA audits that have been conducted
among many of our boards in the last 10
years reflect is that
we inherited a lot of dysfunctional
boards in in terms of processes and
that's not to say that it was
intentional I think it was just the
nature of the volunteer
um you know part of the process it was
performed by volunteers without a lot of
oversight from from State actors who
understood administrative processes and
so it's not that oplc is just a new
agency with a fresh start we really are
still in the discovery phase of
fixing a lot of processes and procedures
that are not consistent with statutory
requirements so that has to be our first
strategic goal and our plan is to
hopefully make sure that we're
fulfilling all of our statutory
requirements by fy25
consistent with the governor's
directives we'd like to enhance customer
service increase licensure portability
that really goes to the workforce
barriers that we talked about earlier
and to promote public protection which
of course is the goal of any regulatory
licensure board
so if you turn to the next page we
really have
two types of major initiatives or
strategies that are going to help us
achieve our strategic goals the first is
really leveraging technology
a lot of the processes that we have
observed in the office that are
long-standing their legacy processes
they are manually they're manually
driven require you know intense labor
efforts a lot of Staff we that's not
sustainable as we know even if we had
access to a lot of money which we which
we don't
um we just can't find the people to
perform the job so we need to really
leverage technology in a way that's
efficient and economic and that will
allow us to sustain agency operations
moving forward without the need for many
staff so we are working right now we're
on implementing a new licensing portal
this obviously was recommended by many
um LBA audits as well it's an Enterprise
solution it's fully funded by arpa
dollars we started this project actually
we had a kickoff meeting this week this
is going to take several years
um but we do anticipate that hopefully
by the end of the next biennium that we
will have transitioned to a completely
new Solution that's modernized and in
providing the customer service that we
need we also just recently entered into
a question yes thank you Mr chairman
what's the what's this current state can
most people who are licensed
renew their license online and pay
online and apply online and things like
that or not yet it's really depends on
the board we moved all renewal licenses
online
um
last session we have not been able to
move all initial licenses online mainly
because the current system is supported
directly by Duit and not vendor
supported and they're having their own
Staffing challenges there's only two
part-time contractors who are able to
support the entire State's needs in
terms of development work and they only
work you know a couple days a week and
it's not just oplc it's Lottery it's
liquor it's safety all competing for
those resources so we have basically put
on hold any transition to an electronic
platform those initial licenses
so this new technology is a um a vendor
supported yes okay yes representative
so the other type of uh solution that
we've entered into is uh continuing
education solution
um we are a lot of our uh licensing
staff spend a lot of time reviewing
paper applications micromanaging
continuing education of licensees this
portal uh which is actually a no cost
contract will allow licensees to track
their continuing education online search
for courses you know provide a visual
roadmap as to whether or not they've
satisfied
um their their needs and at some point
we'll interface the two systems so that
they speak to each other and we don't
have to engage in multiple different
systems
but these two solutions which I think
are going to be game changers for for
both Workforce and for the agency
um it requires that we have internal
controls and that is a consistent theme
that we've seen in all of the LBA audits
that have been performed on our boards
but also observed by us working in the
office there has been a consistent lack
of internal controls throughout the
agency and the boards and so we are
really embarking on a very aggressive
effort to establish those internal
controls
um part of that process has been to
inventory all statutory and regulatory
requirements
our regulatory framework is is huge it's
I would say it's about four times the
size of Labor
um and we have about similar budgets and
you know similar size staff
um just because of we have 50-something
practice acts plus our own practice acts
it's just it's just quite voluminous and
there are a lot of conflicts so it has
required extensive effort by attorneys
to do this work what we've observed in
the past is that staff
web words have not necessarily
interpreted the law correctly and have
implemented processes that are contrary
to law and so we feel it's very
important to get it right and that we
transition any new license type into a
new system in a manner that reflects
what the statutory directives are so we
have reviewed all renewal
requirements uh both statutory and
Regulatory we are now transitioning to
renewing uh to reviewing all initial
licensing applications and then and we
are developing policies and procedures
to reflect
um
the intent of the statue to make sure
that we have internal controls
all of that takes a lot of work and
that's why I think this Governor's
recommended budget is really intended to
permit us to continue to achieve those
initiatives
um
we it it does propose an increase in
Appropriations primarily and in the
following classes Personnel related
costs and Class 10 and class 60
and then you know as well as some some
other related
overhead costs you know the lease for
example which is contemplated in class
22 as well as class 30 which has to do
with replacing our depreciated vehicles
what I Envision though is that as we
gear up we're we're expending great
effort utilizing our existing staff to
continue to allow the agency to function
while cleaning up the mess on the side
and then at some point when we get to
the end which should be sometime in fy25
we will we will realize that we don't
need the same amount of administrative
support to continue
so I fully anticipate that once our
initiatives are completed we will see
Savings in both class 10 and class 60
due to redo reduced staff support that's
necessary and we we anticipate achieving
that through attrition of course if at
all possible
um
so if we go through class items in a
little bit greater detail class 10 we
are proposing to convert six existing
temporary positions to permanent
positions so they are already working in
the agency on the initiatives that I've
mentioned
these are higher level positions and on
the next page they're they're spelled
out there are two business analyst
positions those are basically in our I.T
group two attorneys an administrator
who's dedicated to establishing internal
controls and a licensing supervisor
which was really just necessary to
ensure compliance with the law
class 22 was our move to Eagle Square
which you may remember we previously
were in Philbrook and DHHS needed the
building for transitional housing so we
left and procured at least space but it
was done I would say virtually overnight
but it was in 30 days and
um our lease is expensive as you can see
in class 22 so we are already planning
ahead preparing for when that least ends
exploring all options as to whether
there's any way to reduce our overhead
with respect to class 22.
class 30 the governor's proposed budget
proposes 252 500 dollars in FY 2024 this
was largely intended to replace fully
depreciated vehicles
we do not believe that is that is
um still needed as we were able to
um
we're we we are able to purchase some
Vehicles this year there was a question
at the time of the budget it's creation
whether Vehicles would be available
because that's been a long-standing
issue but we do believe that we are
going to be able to purchase them this
year so the large bulk of the funds that
have been proposed in class 30 we don't
believe that we will actually need
um class 46 the increase there is
largely for the Board of Medicine for
Consultants
their current contract for their
statutorily required physician
investigator is much more expensive than
in years prior
and so
um
because it's required by Statute you
know we we believe that we need to have
Appropriations in order to fully fund
that statutory requirement
of course class 60 benefits and then
class 531 I wanted to touch upon this
because
this is a required program for nursing
it's a voluntary program for other
health care professions it's the
professionals health program
what this is is if an individual
um
has substance use disorder issues
um or is in Burnout they can voluntarily
enter this program which can essentially
assist them in getting back into the
workforce in a safe manner on the flip
side if we we can order them to
participate pursuant to disciplinary
action that line item
represents the cost of the contract that
was approved by governor and Council so
that's why there was an increase there
and it's fully funded through fees for
that specific program and it's held in a
dedicated non-lapsing fund so I just
wanted to make note of that
we do plan on utilizing existing agency
funding for these increases I think in
years past we've we've observed
significant lapses to the general fund
this budget this proposed budget does
not contemplate uh really much of a
lapse at all this year
it's difficult to protect our Revenue
because uh because the licensing renewal
Cycles
um vary but based on prior figures we
are projecting a revenue at the close of
this fiscal year about 15.4 million
dollars
and so consistent with that we believe
that we could fully fund this Governor's
proposed budget with existing agency
funds
we um turning to the next page we
discuss the two new positions but I also
wanted to note that we had requested
that if these positions were not
converted to permanent positions that we
would need to at least continue them on
a temporary full-time basis which is why
um
certain you know certain amount of
benefits but as well as class 59 funds
were requested if as if those positions
are established we do not believe that
we would need
approximately 368 000 for FY 24 and 378
000 for fy25 in class 59 and the
corresponding benefits that go along
with that we just we just feel like it's
very important that we continue to
support with the staff that are in
existence and in order to achieve those
initiatives that I mentioned earlier
thank you so is the ones in the book
um 59s or tens
36.
are they
they're so actually so 59 now they're 59
now and we didn't know if we would we
were kind of hedging our bets we didn't
know if we would get them in class then
and so requested that we can continue to
have appropriated funds for class 59
but our plan was if that the class 59
was really intended to just continue the
temporary positions that we have now
um but if converted to 10 which they are
also included in 10 we wouldn't
necessarily need those funds in class
59.
because I I notice maybe these are the
ones
um if you look on page 188
um
licensing board Administration there's a
new set of 59s
318 326.
yeah yes and we don't believe that we
would need to continue with those funds
if these positions were converted
um to permanent
and it'll be roughly a watch yeah
essentially
so I did want to address
um what we believe may be the
anticipated reductions in Revenue
um as a result of uh the governor's
proposed trailer bill in hb2
we've done the analysis as you know the
governor has proposed to eliminate
certain license types many of which are
within oplc we believe that that would
result in a reduction of Revenue across
the biennium of approximately 953
um thousand
that said
we believe that there are opportunities
for potential increases in Revenue so it
it's hard to say whether we would
actually see a net loss the governor has
proposed uh essentially Universal
licensure recognition which we do
believe would likely result in increased
number of applications to our office the
only data that I can point to really is
the emergency licensing process because
we believe that the criteria would be
basically the same and we observed 22
000 additional licensing applications
that year 63 percent of psychologists in
New Hampshire who are practicing were
doing so under only under an emergency
license so it is likely that if that
change were made we could actually see
an increase in Revenue but it's it's
it's still unclear because we don't have
access to the data
so I do have a question on that I'm
trying to follow you we're going to lose
perhaps a million dollars but by
allowing people from other states to
accept their license why aren't they
applying now
to become part of the state's system if
you will our requirements much more
stringent is that why they're not
applying
is a fee different
I think it's tough to tell to be honest
and it varies by profession I will tell
you for for example psychology has much
more stringent requirements you have to
go back and find your supervisor who may
be deceased you have to get your
transcripts you have to get you know all
of this extra stuff even if you've been
practicing for 30 years and what's
contemplated is that you would just have
to present the fact that you have a
valid license in another state that's in
good standing pay the fee and come on in
anecdotally I have you know people have
explained they don't like coming to New
Hampshire because the process is so you
know ridiculous and their words not mine
that said there are other license types
within oplc that are that are perfectly
um streamlined and efficient so it
really is it really is tough to tell
so just to follow up to that you're
saying this is a streamlining
but I see your
funds are necessary funds to run your
organization will be going up
substantially
and you're adding more staff so
help me try to get my head around the
fact that it's going to be better for us
if we lower the amount of money we're
coming in it's increasing costs and
we're adding more employees
I think one of the challenges with oplc
is that it it wasn't set up for success
in terms of resources at the beginning
um
in order to really undo the dysfunction
that was the licensing process created
by all of these independent regulatory
boards that have no expertise in
administrative law and procedure we need
we need resources to do that I think
that's a short-term use of resources and
that's why we are proposing this
increase in Appropriations to get
through these initiatives
but like I mentioned I think after those
initiatives are completed we will see
that we don't need as much staff we
don't need as much overhead
um it's possible we may not need as much
space
but we won't really know that until we
get through these initiatives to really
move our processes to an electronic
portal that's not a manually driven
process
I have some more questions but I'll
yield to represent camberells thank you
Mr chair out of the 1061 positions you
currently have
that was a mistake okay so out of the
positions you currently have
um what is the vacancy rate are you
fully staffed or we are not fully
staffed um well I should say we have
many vacant temporary positions right
now we have 32 positions that are vacant
so with our temporary and our permanent
positions combined we actually have 126
authorized positions 32 of which
combined are vacant
we only selected six to try to move to
permanent and they are already filled
positions
follow-up yeah and uh what are your what
do you believe are your chances of being
successful and not only filling those
but putting in the additional positions
are you having a hard time hiring right
now I think our challenges right now are
hiring at our licensing clerk level
because it's it's an entry level
position
um and it it's just a challenge to hire
those types of individuals which is why
I think it's so critical that we move
away from manual processes that require
them to you know review the paper and we
allow customer self-service through an
electronic platform and that's what
these initiatives are intended to do is
really transform the way we do business
the six positions that we are requesting
in this budget are currently filled in
temporary positions obviously they would
have to apply because that's the process
but they are filled
further questions yes represent Griffin
get a feeling that seven advisors
what makes a difference
certainly so these are boards that
advise
the agency
um regarding licensure criteria what the
rules should be for example massage
therapy is an Advisory board so they
don't have their independent Authority
they have greater State oversight they
convene meetings and they review
complaints and they make recommendations
But ultimately it's the agency's
determination about what to do with that
complaint
I like that model mainly because it
provides the requisite stay oversight
um that you know that was deemed
necessary out of the Supreme Court case
in 2015 North Carolina Dental Delta
Dental
um essentially you know that said that
when you have regulatory boards
comprised of active Market participants
people in the fields
um that the state is not entitled to
immunity from antitrust
suits and claims unless their state
oversight and in the case of advisory
boards there is State oversight because
there's essentially veto power if for
example they would make a decision
that's based on anything other than
protecting the public and and clear
objective standards
during The Question
but um I guess I'd like to know a couple
of the other boards that are advisory
certainly um so it's massage therapy
body art Medical Imaging court reporters
um reflexology Asian Bodywork therapists
I do have a list that I'll give to the
entire division they're like 53 54
different
areas that we license and just as long
as we're on the whole topic once we get
House Bill 2 with the proposed changes
I'm going to send this over to Edna
I think some of the problems that we've
experienced to be quite candid is that
the process was rushed through the
finance committee several years ago and
so I've reached out to the chair over
there to suggest that we move this over
they'll have a couple of weeks and give
a good look see because I believe there
are about 300 pages I was told dealing
with these changes and it's a major
policy shift for us so I think it should
go to the policy committee for their
recommendations and thoughts
so just to let everybody know
representative
representative hatch you have a question
that's right representative McGuire
thank you Mr chairman so to follow up on
representative Griffin's question are
these boards advising you
not so you're the ones that make a
decision about uh licensing or not
licensing or how to discipline or that
sort of stuff is that right correct we
we rely heavily on their recommendations
but at the end of the day and I'll give
you a prime example the board of body
art practitioners is an Advisory Board a
couple years back they decided that they
would like to create a license type for
microblading which would allow
estheticians which are licensed under a
different board to perform
um provide tattoo services in a certain
limited scope they pursued that
legislation I believe is with
representative McGuire
um and uh and it was successful and then
it came time to Draft rules and they
heard from all of their colleagues in
the community who did not want an influx
of individuals competing with them and
they decided oh I don't want to write
rules
and the agency was able to say well this
is our statutory directive we have to so
I would appreciate your advice but
otherwise we're just going to move
forward and that's what we did and but
that's a prime example of why I think
State oversight can play a critical role
we do have to have a collaborative
relationship because you really do need
to marry the expertise of the profession
with expertise of you know overseeing a
state agency but um but it's important I
think to have a supervision
thank you going back to um this list of
reduced Revenue the pink thing
um
Booth that's not all Barbers right
that's that's
no it it's their independent contractors
within licensed facilities and we did
some legislate we did some research we
went to archives and what we could
figure out was that
we think Booth licensure came about as
around the time of you know the 1930s
when Mary Kay was popular and um it was
a mechanism to really Empower female
women to own their own businesses I
think and so this is that actually
elimination and that repeal is supported
by the Board of barbering cosmetology
and Aesthetics because it doesn't really
serve a purpose because the facility is
already inspected so they're just
inspecting you know 10 people within the
same facility that's inspected it's just
not necessary
or other questions
yes represent cambrells yes thank you Mr
chair just to go back you did say that
leasing was an opportunity to maybe
reduce costs uh when does the current
lease expire for
2032.
I mean there are always opportunities
right for the state to to take a
different direction but um we're not in
a position right now to do that but we
are planning for that
um in the future
so in addition to potential unknown
increases in Revenue lastly I just
wanted to mention that we could see a
potential decreases in expenditures if
what the governor has proposed in house
poll 2 were to pass certainly the fact
that we have to support a large number
of boards has a cost component to it you
know through administrative burdens and
I think we could see a reduction in
those costs
um board members also receive per diems
they receive other reimbursements we
could see a reduction in that and then
also see a reduced need for an
administrative support in class 10 and
class 60 due to streamline licensing and
disciplinary procedures and ultimately I
think that's where we'll end up
regardless of hb2 once we see that our
procedures are a little bit more refined
after this next biennium we anticipate
that with our current staffer or even
reduced staff we will be able to
maintain agency operations
with that I'd be happy to answer any
additional questions
for the director representative McGuire
thank you so can I assume that all this
new stuff eliminating those licenses and
boards and so on is not really reflected
in the budget yet is that right no it's
not
um because what's proposed also is to
transfer certain boards to us we've seen
those budgets but we don't know what the
revenue is for those boards so that
would still have to be incorporated
you're working on a fiscal note for
House Bill 2 is that
sure at some point
some point Mr Hoffman
once House Bill 2 was introduced we
usually send it to all the agencies
um
we rarely have a completed fiscal note
just because the process involves
everyone and it's just overwhelming
for those of you new to finance Mr
Hoffman and I were joking earlier that
all the balls are just all up in the air
right now we hope they fall in the right
place in a couple of weeks but they
usually do or have in the past
further questions just representative
thank you
requirement for these categories would
be
taken away and otherwise when could they
start operating without a license do you
have a sense of that I think that would
be based on the effective date provided
in hp2 I'm just wondering if you yeah
but I wondered I mean we hope that we
have a budget on July 1 and if that's
the case that it's effective on July 1
and so we could see some changes at that
point
any further questions uh I do have one
more so obviously there's been a lot of
discussion among the different boards
that you're overseeing now what's been
the general reaction
nobody is happy
nobody is Happy well
we have good relationships with a large
majority of boards I think many of them
understand the changes that are proposed
but they do not like them I think
another component of licensure is that
which is not really reflected in statute
is that licensure can be become part of
one's professional identity whether it
should or should not and so there are
some emotions and feelings surrounding
discussions about whether licensure is
truly needed in order to protect the
public or whether or not we can rely on
a less restrictive manner to do so
um the agency you know just looks
forward to collaborating with the
legislature on this process and and
working with the boards to kind of help
them navigate but we do have different
um
different statutory missions well you
raise a good point because a number of
people will say I'm licensed by the
state of the New Hampshire so there's
some assurance that it could be safe or
there'll be good work done or they're
not as you know a con artist or
something so I can see where people use
that as an advantage
so certainly and licensure really is
just to ensure that minimum standards
are satisfied are satisfied so
further questions represent McGuire uh
representative hatch yes yes thank you
thank you for coming
back did you have advisory boards and
governance boards
how involved are you where they have a
governance Force it's just
administratively primarily or how do you
intersect
so I think we have a little bit more
um in the game other than you know as
opposed to an administrative peer
administrative attachment
because the office over the last couple
of years has obtained certain regulatory
Authority for example we now have
regulatory authority over licensing
procedures and investigative procedures
we just uh um promulgated rules for
investigative procedures and are now
um actually today I filed uh the final
proposal for licensing procedures
part of the challenge with oplc though
is that we're we're trying to work
collaboratively with the board so we
have gone to each one of them and said
can you please repeal your investigative
rules so we can use ours
um and we're making good Headway but it
it just takes time and we anticipate
that to be the case with the licensing
procedures we could say we have
statutory Authority
um and at some point we may get to that
if we have a couple holdouts but so far
we've we've preferred to take a
collaborative approach
yes represent evil so um
[Music]
uh license types propose to be
eliminated did you influence these
categories could you give us some
background on how these particular ones
were selected
I wouldn't say I influenced I I was
consulted the agency is typically
consulted with these types of structural
changes
um I can I can say that I think the
governor's overall goal is really to
ensure that
um we are only
um
requiring licensure if it's absolutely
necessary to protect the public and is
the least restrictive means of doing so
you know I can I can tell you licensed
nursing assistance for example that's
just a duplicative process that already
exists because we're mandated by the
federal government to maintain a nurse
aide registry so
um while it's proposed that licensed
nursing assistance would be repealed we
would still be required to maintain the
nurse aid registry and have a mechanism
for dealing with professional misconduct
booths were actually supported by the
Board of barbering cosmetology
anesthetics
and then MRT and med techs those were
very recently added
and if you look at all of the boards
that have license types that are
suggested to be repealed we have
received few if any complaints and few
if any reported actions and so I think
the question is whether or not you know
in way the bad benefits of licensure to
protect the public the risks of
potential harm with the workforce
barriers and we have significant
Workforce needs in this state you know
where is that balance and I think we'll
see that through the legislative process
I'm glad you mentioned Ellen A's because
that was one that I was uh interested I
mean we've already heard about Foresters
could you talk about Foresters
I can't talk too much about forcers
other than to say that they don't and
they haven't received numerous
complaints or reported decisions and I
think the question is whether or not
um there's a national credential or
other certification that could
reasonably protect the public as opposed
to State mandated licensure
and what's a natural scientist those are
your Wetland scientists soil scientists
further questions I do have one you your
group if you will provide some
significant funding occasionally back to
the general fund how will this impact
anything that we get back
so
um the governor's proposed budget
is approximately 50 million dollars our
estimated revenue is approximately 15
million dollars
um and so therefore we would anticipate
a nearly zero laps while we're on that
topic
um that there is a committee established
last year to review PLC finances funding
in particular
through Senate Bill 330 it was a
bipartisan committee and they made three
recommendations one of which which is
that now oplc's funds should not lapse
to the general fund I think that's
really important because we have
historically lapsed significant sums of
money compared to our expenditures and
it has essentially amounted to at times
attacks and there's a constitutional way
to do that which is not this way and
um I I really think that if we are going
to require licensure which is a
Workforce barrier we need to make sure
that we're you know extremely efficient
in the way we do so we're not creating
unnecessary barriers and the resources
that we've received through licensing
fees should support licensing fees and
not other parts of the general fund
just one follow-up to that so is there
any money included going back to the
general fund in the next biennium or is
that are you saying that
that would no longer occur based on the
proposal that's in House Bill too
well I think the proposal in House Bill
2 also includes a proposal to make our
fund non-lapsing
if that were not the case and we
continued to Labs fund at the end of the
biennium we would have to either reduce
our expenses or raise our fees in order
to laugh some money to the general fund
because this proposed budget in-house
Bill one is essentially a zero lapse
budget
all right any
further questions seeing now we'll
probably have you back happy to you
anytime the DNA group you have a bite of
the Apple thank you very much appreciate
your time thank you
all right so we have 10 minutes
for those of you that weren't here this
morning
we had kind of a robust discussion with
a lot of folks and uh
we have the judicial Council coming in
on Thursday at 9 00 A.M
their budget is up substantially over
the last budget I mean substantially
and they had quite a handout and there
were a lot of questions and we kind of
ran over with the other little groups
that we saw so Thursday at 9 30
and representative Bryant I mean I hope
Brian Maguire I don't know where that
came from oh yeah used to be friendly
with him
yeah
yes so um
is this is this extra 10 million in the
budget is that similar to what they get
out of the fiscal committee here
piecemeal
that wasn't I don't think it was oh okay
and that's why I asked them how much
they had given because it's not
reflected in their budget okay so that
additional money Mike was about three
million dollars for those last two it
was like a similar in that neighborhood
for two requests and they told us they
have to come back for another two
requests of fistful so again for those
of you not familiar with the process
so it being two o'clock we have the
judicial branch
uh Mr chief justice hey buddy
how it works yeah
our apologies for not doing that sooner
so
so it's all yours okay
Mia please uh you Mr chairman
members of the division one uh for the
record my name is Gordon McDonald and I
serve as the Chief Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court with me our
Superior Court chief justice Tina NATO
Circuit Court Deputy administrative
judge Susan Ashley
director of the administrative
Administrative Office of the courts
Diane Martin
and our judicial branch fiscal manager
Donna Raymond we are very grateful for
the opportunity to present the judicial
Branch's proposed budget request for
fiscal years 24 and 25. you were all
very generous with your time just a
couple weeks ago on February 1st when we
met with you to discuss our way to
caseload study
um and and during that time we're able
to present basic information about the
structure of the judicial branch some of
our current initiatives and of course
the way to caseload study I'm going to
skip all of that in the interest of the
efficiency because I think every member
was there and for those who weren't and
won a copy of our slides from that
session I've got them with me I have a
much shorter set of slides here for us
today
um and I'd ask you just to go to slide
two
our mission statement and
um
the work of our employees all the
members of the judicial branch judges
and Court staff is rooted in our St in
our constitution part one article 35
provides that it is quote it is
essential to the preservation of the
rights of every individual the life
liberty property and character that
there be an impartial interpretation of
the laws and administration of justice
is the right of every citizen to be
Tried by judges as impartial as the lot
of humanity will permit
the proper functioning of an independent
Judiciary is absolutely essential to our
democracy
if you skip a trend to page three
you'll remember that we have two trial
courts the circuit court and Superior
Court and on pages three and four
you will remember the volume of cases
that we confront in the judicial branch
between our two trial courts in excess
of 150 000 cases a year
meaning that our work directly touches
on the lives of so many people in our
state in matters of great and immediate
accordance to them in the decisions of
the Supreme Court are binding on us all
a responsibility we just discharge with
great humility and respect
as chairman Weiler said at the last time
we were together the legislature has
provided in RSA nine colon 4A that as a
separate branch of government the
judicial branch submits its budget along
with uh executive agency branch agency
budgets however the governor may not
change the budget as submitted but may
provide comments as deemed appropriate
and as the chairman noted that provides
an opportunity for our two branches to
engage directly on the needs of the
judicial branch the governor provided no
comments with our budget and we're here
to present what we are proposing to the
committee today
uh although this division may have some
comments but okay
of course
um
slide six
to frame up
um basic concepts governing our budget
and give you some context
number one we are we essentially deliver
Professional Services broadly speaking
so
we are Personnel 73 of our budget is
Personnel is committee division well
knows those costs are essentially fixed
beyond our Personnel costs we have
limited control over many of our cost
centers we make transfers to our share
to the county sheriffs for security and
our Superior Courts we transfer
funds to the Bureau of Court facilities
for the maintenance and
the maintenance of our core facilities
and I'll note on that we'll get to it a
little bit later but
that cost a loan this year out of our
117 million dollar request is 11.2
million dollars
and that's a 16 increase that we've
absorbed this year
we also have
essentially limited control over
technology costs
95 of of the judicial branches generally
funded
the next slide
um
since the budget was prepared and
submitted we have some adjustments I'd
like to go over with the division
number one for both fiscal years we'd
ask that 126
000 be taken out those were for rental
payments we anticipated at one Granite
place we anticipated at one time one
granted place which is the facility that
has houses our trial court Center in
Administrative Office of Courts we do
not need that
um security
closed circuit and alarms you'll see
later on that we are
we are investing in our court security
however These funds are covered by an
ARP request
that was approved earlier in the year or
last year so we are asking that 280 000
in fiscal 24 and 210 000 in fiscal 25.
be removed from our submit our submitted
request
we have
salaries that when we constructed the
budget we were unsure if there would be
Grant funded now we are assured that
they are Grant funded so those can come
out
and then finally on benefits
when we submitted the budget we used
benefit figures provided to us by the
department of administrative Services
the rates have since been revised
however they were revised we received
the revisions too late to incorporate in
the budget and uh the net of that is we
are our health rates have gone down our
Dental rates have gone up very slightly
and we also
are providing for paid family medical
leave but the bottom line is for for
both of uh the fiscal years you can see
where we're asking them 527
000 and 559 000 be removed from our
submission
on the next slide you'll see an overview
of our request against FY 22 actual and
the adjusted authorized for this fiscal
year
um
you can see our original budget
submission and then less the
subtractions that we just went over or
total requests for the first year the
biennium is 116 million 846
7913 dollars that is a 6.1 percent
increase over FY 23 adjusted authorized
uh for fy25 the request is 120 million
377 193 dollars and that is a three
percent increase over the first year of
the biennium
the next slide uh three basic objectives
framed are submission
one is to begin to address the needs
identified in the way to caseload study
the second is to enhance our court
security and the third is to respond to
employ inflationary pressures affecting
our employee retention and or technology
so the next slide should look somewhat
familiar to you this is um copy the
picture of the copy of the way to
caseload report that was prepared last
year and you'll recall that the way the
caseload study is an evidence-based
assessment of the Personnel that are
required to process cases in our two
trial courts
um and this budget as you will see our
request is overwhelmingly the increase
that we're asking for is overwhelmingly
based on on the way to caseload study
the next slide should look familiar to
you
um
our budget request based on the way to
caseload study is for seven new judges
in the Circuit Court
and as we went over the study concluded
we needed 17 and one new Superior Court
Judge of the three and a half that study
asked for called for
with respect to court process case
processing staff
were asking for 31 new staff in the
Circuit Court
and in addition to that one new Clerk
and in the Superior Court four news
staff and in addition to that one new
law Clerk
I did have a question Mr chief justice
is that the courthouse where
representative Hewitt used to preside
her your honor
are you in the window there attention
uh next slide
we need to
we need to address Courthouse Security
in the budget before you our request
um
takes on to is it is what I would
characterize an initial investment over
this biennium and addressing Courthouse
security
just to step back
our Courthouse security is provided by
two
two entities one is uh court security
officers which are employees of the
administrative office of Courts and they
provide security in our circuit courts
and then in our in our Superior Courts
we pay the county sheriffs to provide
security in those courthouses for our
court security officers
um they are not equipped with their own
weapons
and their own ammunition and we need to
get standardized equipment for what I
think would be fairly obvious reasons
um
we are also investing in additional
protective equipment and although it
says training here that is that is there
are no funds included for training but
it is part of a legislative request that
we're making uh that you'll see in a
separate bill we're asking that our csos
and and deputies
undertake a
course that we're going to work with a
training regimen to be undertaken by
police standards in training councils so
they'll go through a regular training
and certification process over there
which we have not been doing
next slide
discusses are
increases related to inflation we
discussed when we were together last
time our difficulty in retaining
many of our core processing staff
our front line staff dealing with the
public court assistance two and three
or information center representatives in
our our proposal there is to adjust
their labor grade labor grades to better
to get their
compensation to a level where we're just
going to be more competitive we are
literally as I think judge king
mentioned when we were together last we
were we are losing Court staff to fast
food establishments and uh our turnover
our efforts to retain and train those
staff is is a continual challenge
represent Maguire has a question thank
you Mr chairman thank you Mr chief
justice this says per diem are these um
folks not on the salary
on the next bullet point yeah where it
says increase security officer per diem
rate from 121. our
um court security Personnel are
overwhelmingly part-time and per diem uh
we have 119 per diem officers and I
think our total security force is
probably 130 we have some full-time and
some part-time some full-time one
training officer so it's overwhelmingly
per diem
um and so this increases again to keep
us competitive with a really tight labor
market for those per diem officers
so then there's no benefits correct
right and
um
are these um officers
oh okay we do have uh
we do have I'm sorry I'm being corrected
there are some per diem officers who
work four and five days who do get
benefits gotcha and
but the others that are part-time
their officers and some town uh police
department or state troopers or the most
many of them are retired law enforcement
I see
um I I don't know if we have current law
enforcement in our
no
most most of them are retired law
enforcement but certainly not all or
gotcha thank you
so that covers the second bullet point
and then three
um
we're asking for uh
increase funds to respond to uh
really significant inflationary
pressures on on technology
uh next slide uh we're just going to
cover some other additions in this
budget and I'm going to ask chess it's
NATO to talk about the drug court
thanks everyone I know we talked a
little bit about the program last time
and I want to
um thank you for your time today to
listen to me about why we're asking for
an increase in the drug court budget as
you recall back in 2016 when the
legislature created the opioid task
force that's where the legislation
establishing funding for Statewide drug
court was created and since then we have
never had an increase in that funding
it's been static and we've broken it out
into sort of small medium and large
courts and they get a capped amount
based on the size of the court and how
many people they can serve and we've
discovered that similar to what's going
on in the judicial branch we're seeing a
lot of turnover in the therapists and
case managers that work in the drug
court program the drug court folks that
they're dealing with are people that are
the most challenging they're people that
have had intractable substance use
disorders for many years criminal
records so they're really tough to deal
with and this increase it's about a 25
percent increase totaling around 650 000
and that would go to enhance the
salaries and in some depending on the
court and some places maybe add a case
manager that they need so they can grow
the program a bit and the the reason for
that is because when we have turnover
that actually results in poorer outcomes
for the participants once they establish
that Therapeutic Alliance they do better
they improve better they progress and
when they have that turnover they've
actually done studies it takes them a
couple of years or not a couple years it
takes another year to sort of get used
to that therapist and to be able to
continue to progress so we'd like to
hold on to the good ones and we have
having a really hard time doing that the
last thing I'll say is that when this
funding occurred the judicial Grant is
basically sort of the repository for the
funding then we contract out with a
treatment provider and that funding goes
for treatment the coordinator for the
court and case management so we're kind
of the pass-through and that's what
would happen with this money it would be
a further investment in the program that
you've already created to make sure we
can keep hold of those therapists and
case managers so I'm happy to answer any
questions anything else
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question sure
um so you said treatment so is is the
funding for that treatment through the
judiciaries budget as opposed to HHS or
where I would normally think of as
treatment exactly you you the
legislature has appropriated that money
into our budget we have a line for it
drug court budget line so it doesn't get
mixed up with everything else and then
we contract with an agency to provide
the services sort of like HHS would do
but it makes a little bit more sense for
us because the people we're dealing with
are those who have got a lengthy
criminal record that might otherwise be
headed to State Prison if they didn't
have this option so it helps us we have
we have memorandums of understanding
that we sign with the therapy with the
therapists and the team works together
so that that is how it's funded through
our budget
um
so I would assume that you don't have
like Medical Offices or something you're
you're Contracting with somebody yeah
and they go to their office right so
sometimes people think why are Judges
being therapists we are not being
therapists so for example the Elliott
hospital is our contractor for the uh
Hillsborough North drug court program
and they have therapists psychiatrists
mental health provider case manager and
the coordinator and they manage all of
the treatment that people go to their
facility to receive the treatment they
get group therapy individual counseling
and they show up in court weekly for
their check-ins I see thank you okay
any further questions on the yes
represent Weiler
thank you Mr chairman
judge NATO yes we're not able to get a
straight answer how many illegal aliens
have been shipped to our state I wonder
if you're seeing them in the courts
wow that's a good question I you know we
are required for example at a plea
hearing to make sure the public defender
has inquired of their client whether or
not a resulting plea would have
immigration implications but we don't
keep track of of that so we do not know
you're not seeing a big up service no no
I'm not thank you okay
brother questions I guess you're off the
hook for now
um still on slide 14. it's uh director
Martin come up and talk about the some
of our other budget
Editions
um the data management analyst position
that's something that we included
um the judicial branch is a repository
obviously for a lot of information and
everybody is interested in that
information so we get a lot of requests
for for our data from all sources but
even from the legislature I think we've
had several this week and we only and in
addition to that the data is useful to
the court and being able to look at its
processes who's using them and come up
with
um better approaches to Things So
currently we have a single person only
in the Circuit Court who's who is
available to do that work and she is not
able to keep up with the requests for
data so this position would be created
Branch wide and it would help to address
those requests and other needs for data
throughout the branch on a on a
branch-wide basis do you want to skip
down okay the other mention here that I
was going to cover is the grant program
expansion so we were fortunate enough to
hire a grant manager through the drug
court Grant who is excellent she came
from doj she has a lot of experience and
in order to have her spend some time
looking for other potential grants that
that we could get to to continue to do
good work in the in the drug courts in
the family treatment Court mental health
courts all of those areas she can't be
just working on the drug court Grant
because we would have to charge it to
that Grant and we're not allowed to do
that so this allows us to
pay a portion of her salary with General
funds for a period of time as we grow
the grant program our ultimate goal is
to be somewhat like doj and have a Grant
Management unit that is completely
self-funded so this would allow us to
move in that direction
any questions
judge Ashley's going to talk about
interpreters yes
yes so um obviously the court is
required to provide an interpreter to
anyone who's participating in a court
process
and that's clearly an issue that we
don't have control over as far as how
many requests that we get we need to
provide that we have and it's an it's a
critical access to justice issue for
folks we have promoted the availability
of interpreters by making sure that we
have appropriate signage in our courts
so that folks understand if they come in
they speak a different language that
they can make that request for an
interpreter what we've seen through the
years has been a gradual uptick in the
cost of our total budget for
interpreters we've made requests for a
specific amount of money for
interpreters and then you've probably
seen us come back Midway through saying
that we've run out of that money we need
to have some additional money so there's
been a big increase if you look between
maybe
2019 and and 2022 went up about a
hundred and ten thousand and so that's
why our budget is going up on that line
item in particular this time around is
to make sure that we've got enough money
in that pool hopefully to avoid us
having to come back again Midway through
and say we have run out once again
and so that's
the issue with interpreters I'm happy to
try to answer any questions you may have
yes representative Sweeney thank you
chairman thank you for being here um
when you say interpreters are is it
mainly foreign language or is it Amer
American Sign Language yes
absolutely is there a breakdown as to
how what's foreign language and what's
sign language I don't have that detail
but I don't know if any
body for the hearing impaired language
thank you
representative
yeah so are you are you having to find
folks for many different languages now
than you used to and are they hard to
find sometimes yes and yes
um and and frankly the pandemic has as
it has impacted many
areas in many Industries it certainly
has made it more difficult for us to
find interpreters for quite a while we
had to do hearings
remotely and many of our interpreters
were doing just that and they have been
how shall I say
a little reluctant to come back in to do
things in person so it's making it much
more difficult on our staff to make sure
that we've got appropriate interpreters
in all of the cases
and of course the expansion of of
different languages
is also an issue so it is a struggle but
we continue to make sure that we have
someone when we need to have them for
any of our hearings
are there a couple of particular
languages in particular that you've seen
an increase in I'm curious because it
would be reflective probably of new
citizens that are coming I think so I
mean clearly you know the yes I mean
Spanish is is our primary language that
we're seeing interpreters for but there
are different immigrant immigrant
immigrant populations that we're seeing
that we're getting additional inquiries
and but there's so many dialects out
there that
um it it sometimes is difficult to make
sure that we've got the the appropriate
interpreter for the appropriate language
and then to the question about hearing
impaired those interpretation
um needs are actually
um double every time that you have a
someone who is hearing impaired we need
to have two and that's just because of
the process by which they they do that
so it's you know sometimes if you have a
parenting case and both parents are deaf
then you've got four interpreters that
you need it can be quite challenging
along those lines
but we continue to sort of shake the
bushes and try to make sure we've got
enough folks on board to do these really
important work to make sure that people
can understand the proceedings that
they're in
yes representing camberells thank you Mr
chair just out of curiosity is it a flat
fee for any kind of language inter or do
you have to pay more money for certain
languages another
excellent question I'm gonna turn behind
me
as well
if it's still somewhere in order to
interpret these types of terms sometimes
um it's conversational where you you
know the latest window I think they get
new work they're a very political person
in that and I think also more rare types
of languages require higher as well so
they're not
thank you very much
Ashley
so the final slide is Slide 15.
and
um
the point of this slide is to establish
that and and to convey to the committee
that that the request our budget is
basically
uh uh is is heavily founded on our
evidence-based way State way to caseload
study the overall uh increase in our
budget as we saw in slide 8 is 6.1
percent if you back out our requests
related to weighted caseload we're at
point four percent we're essentially
flat funded
so we we're trying to be very prudent
stewards and partners in in managing uh
public finances
um but we're here we're here asking for
the legislature to support this division
support in in meeting the needs that
were identified in the way to caseload
study
with with that Mr chairman respectfully
submitted
I don't see any questions other than
representative McGuire to my left but I
I do have one for Donna out there I no
she's she could tell us how many pencils
that you ordered or pens and from past
history I don't think I would
like you'll see there you go
so on page 198 of your budget
there's a line 27 22 it says Court
Improvement project fyo seven
back in 2012 now how time flies
um that accounting unit existed and I
asked about it and at the time the
judicial branch was primarily generally
funded as the chief justice has spoken
about we're trying to build a grants
management division but grants were
pretty much an afterthought it was
really General funds and I believe
there may have been a few grants that we
had at the time but this accounting unit
was created to sort of be representative
of the federal grants that we had there
was some discussion with this go around
to maybe in a in an effort to be more
transparent to maybe list those
accounting units for the federal grants
that we get on a regular basis they're
not a lot of money but we do get them
year after year a lot of the other
grants that we have now tend to be
competitive grants so we're never sure
that we're going to get them and the
timing sometimes isn't right but we have
had discussions about maybe updating
that and not just have this one
accounting unit to be representative of
our federal grants it caught my eye
because it had gone from 350 to over 800
000 so it kind of stuck out yes and
that's because we a lot of it is the
salaries and benefits so basically
people who staff whom we have now that
are funded through these federal grants
they go into that accounting unit bucket
if you will
yes any questions uh further
representative McGuire
thank you none of them this specific
yeah yeah all right thank you so yeah
this question might might be better
directed at judge NATO I think
um because about Superior Court
um so I'm looking on page four
17 825 cases you have 30 judges
22 yep
Oh I thought it was 30 going to 31.
we have we have 21
associate Justice one chief justice the
weighted caseload study called for three
and a half new judges I see and we're
asking for one dungeon all right so
let's call it 20 then
all right so does does a does a judge
really handle 900 cases yes
yes the new case filings a year so
they're not always working on all of
them at all times so for example one day
they may have from 9 to 10 o'clock 10
plea hearings and then from 10 to 4 a
jury trial or a bench trial or
significant evidentiary hearing so but
they are they are creeping up I remember
when I first started as cheap in 2011
the average number of cases new case
filings per judge per year was between
five and six hundred and now it's up to
900.
so so you could really handle a felony
in 10 minutes or something like that I
mean I know I don't pretend I'm tend to
understand the methadone apology behind
the whole weighted caseload study but I
do trust it so it depends I think
they're including not just a jury trial
but you know a felony plea if it's a
simple one can take five to ten minutes
or 15 minutes depending on the judge
some judges take longer some judges take
shorter so they're folding in all the
plays plus the trials and probably
95 of cases end up in a negotiated
resolution and five percent go to trial
I see so for those 95 it's mostly
reading and signing a piece of paper
seeing them
extend your rights and
sorry do you review the facts and I see
that's interesting
um so so we're talking about adding a
judge yes a land use judge right right
and which you we we agreed is is the
judge right what is the extra judge all
right
how many land use cases do you expect
that judge to handle in a year so
we're from
you know 35 to 50 of their time on the
land use docket it's a little bit
unclear right now but then because the
way to caseload study says we could use
three and a half then we will use the
rest of that judge's time to help manage
the docket probably in Hills North
because it's the busiest
okay so all right so a halftime judge
could handle all the land use cases
roughly
well we don't have any halftime judges
no I know part-time judges
you want to go ahead you can I wanted to
ask so my question is I assume a land
use case is not a 10-minute case right
it's a they're they're long they're
complicated
it's another reason why we think this
would be a good move because it could
help move that docket along so right now
all the judges handle all you know
planning board appeals zoning board
appeals and if they've got an
incarcerated afsa they've got to take
that first so the land you stock it
would be able to prioritize the land use
cases and keep them moving right and do
you do you under do you have an idea of
how many that is because and the reason
I'll tell you the reason I'm asking is
we heard today from the housing appeals
board
okay which is the alternative right in
in a lot of cases right they could go to
Superior Court or they could go to the
house
that's what we heard so they've had it
in two years 65 cases
[Laughter]
the zoning board appeals land use
appeals tax abatement well tax is tax
and land appeal support right so that's
slightly different
be the land you stock it would be a
zoning board Appeals
of those taxes
okay yeah but I mean it's probably more
like on the order of you know 200 to 500
cases or something they're all going to
that land use docket board I see yeah
yeah gotcha all right so you think the
Judge half time
could do these 200 cases and then the
other half do some other right 400 cases
300 kids okay I understand exactly thank
you very much thank you
I believe where representative McGuire
was going as we did have some debate
earlier about the housing appeals board
right and their budgets nearly 900 000
for 65 cases for two years and it's all
General funded
so with this additional position which
was approved by the legislature
announced before our division next
Friday I believe
we were just trying to get a handle on
do we need housing appeals board is this
particular Justice become full-time land
use housing type of thing
and they roughly cost the same each the
judge and and staff versus the housing
appeals board and staff are each about
500 000 a year I can try I can get you a
better number but it is in the hundreds
gotcha thank you representative Sweeney
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
both for for being here everyone here
taking questions talked about security
uh mainly in the courtrooms I I would
imagine and I'm not sure if this has
been an issue in the past or it might be
in the future uh but judges in their
execution of their duties
become public figures some of their
cases are heated
heightened security outside of the
courtroom does that fall on the judicial
branch to provide or or the state police
step in how does that work with the
being a separate branch of government
and if there is a security risk for a
judge or potentially even a jury in a
case yeah so the our court security
officers
um
uh are in our courtrooms and they secure
our buildings
when there's an event involving that
extends beyond the four corners of our
building we will involve local law
enforcement and when appropriate State
Police
further questions from the division
representative evil I actually want to
go back to the housing appeals board so
you implied more of the folks are
tending to still go to the superior
court that is clear yes
yes I have no idea why that's really
interesting
um idea I would only be speculating
it may be that that's what they're used
to and it may be that that's where it
feels most final you know I'm not
comfortable yeah comfortable
because they appeal from the housing
appeals board to the superior to the
Supreme Court right they said they'd had
about four or five cases there and I
think three went to the superior Supreme
Court said three of them went upheld
yeah two are still in this was still in
works in the middle
interesting part of it might be
um commercial cases can't go to the
housing appeals for it so I don't know
if if you know most of those cases in
the spirit Court are commercial and not
residential
commercial
real estate type stuff I don't I mean I
think it's a big mix okay big mix
I've heard a lot of talk about how
important it was to have this and how
lengthy it was to go to court this is
what we really need I heard that for two
years we finally passed it and it's kind
of fizzy
so it sounds like you're going to take
up the physical note on the housing on
the land use docket next week is it
that's the separate bill we're talking
about right
uh
well if it's helpful to the division
we'll we'll we can refine these numbers
and get you something more stable
yep
um
it has been the customary practice of
this division as long as I've been here
this will be my eighth term to approve
the judicial branch budget as presented
again we do ask some questions
don't want to take up my totally Off The
Hook from providing the answers but
it's been moved is it second and
seconded is there any further discussion
on that
seeing none those in favor of the clerk
will call the role and the acceptance of
the judicial branch
budget
and I assume it's also will be
supporting representative Lynn's
suggestion
I think it passed the house
overwhelmingly didn't it representative
Lynn
your house additional yes three four
four seventy four uh four I'm sorry 347.
by a very large margin well this this
brings up a question right is that extra
judge already in no that's this would be
the the position it would become that
position yeah it's a funding for it okay
he's trying to find the role
well I'd also find unusual is they come
back from our first one and so we're
going to cut here we're going to cut
there we're going to cut here what other
what other agency or Department ever
does that they want us to add well
but
obviously obviously the the full budget
is going to be more but they're still
working every minute to try to keep it
at a minimum and I appreciate that I
think that's a good sign that's why we
are more likely to say yes pass it
through they've done their job
thank you very much Mr chairman Mary I
have the role here
you came prepared yes
nobody wants your position no chance of
that please do it
okay this is uh emotions it's past the
by your name and appear in favor and you
can't sell by saying anything if you're
opposed to your same name
yeah
Griffin yes
that's me yes
yes
oh judge here
yay
yes
thank you very much sir thank you Mr
chairman members of the division thank
you very much